At Medcan, we know that life's greatest moments are built on a foundation of good health, from the big milestones to the quiet winds. That's why our annual health assessment offers a physician-led, full-body checkup that provides a clear picture of your health today, and may uncover early signs of conditions like heart disease and cancer. The healthier you means more moments to cherish. Take control of your well-being and book an assessment today. Medcan. Live well for life.
在 Medcan，我们深知人生中最伟大的时刻都建立在健康的基础之上，从重大的里程碑到宁静的微风，莫不如此。这就是为什么我们提供的年度健康评估包含由医生主导的全身检查，它能为您呈现当下的健康状况，并可能及早发现心脏病和癌症等疾病的迹象。您越健康，就越有更多值得珍惜的时刻。掌控您的健康，立即预约评估吧。Medcan，为您的一生健康生活。
Visit medcan.com slash moments to get started. Attawhalpa speaks, Atahualpa needs, Natawalpa commands, bring him gold, from the palaces, from the temples, from all buildings in the great places, from walls of pleasure and roofs of omen, from floors of feasting and ceilings of death, bring him the gold of Kito and Pachakakak, bring him the gold of Kusko and Korikhancha. Bring him the gold of Vilcanota. Bring him the gold of Collie, of E. Marius and Arakepa. Bring him the gold of the Chimu. Put up a mountain of gold and free your son from his prison of clouds. So that was Christopher Plumber, playing Atahalpa, Emperor of the Inca's in Peter Schaffer's play, The Royal Hunter of the Sun, which we've been hearing a lot of in this series. and Atahualpa in that scene is summoning his people to one of the most memorable endeavors in the whole of world history.
访问 medcan.com/moments 开始吧。阿塔瓦尔帕在说话，阿塔瓦尔帕在要求，阿塔瓦尔帕在命令，给他带去黄金，从宫殿里，从神庙里，从伟大之地的所有建筑里，从享乐的围墙和预兆的屋顶下，从宴饮的地面和死亡的天花板上，给他带去基多和帕查卡马克（Pachacamac）的黄金，给他带去库斯科（Cusco）和科里坎查（Koricancha）的黄金。给他带去比尔卡诺塔（Vilcanota）的黄金。给他带去科利（Collie）、埃马里乌斯（E. Marius）和阿雷基帕（Arequipa）的黄金。给他带去奇穆（Chimu）的黄金。堆起一座金山，让他从云端的监狱中重获自由。以上是克里斯托弗·普卢默（Christopher Plummer）在彼得·谢弗（Peter Shaffer）的戏剧《太阳的皇家猎人》（The Royal Hunter of the Sun）中饰演印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕的片段，我们在本系列节目中经常听到这部剧。在这一幕中，阿塔瓦尔帕正在召集他的人民，去完成世界历史上最令人难忘的壮举之一。
And it's the kind of scene that maybe as a child you have a book of world history and you read about it and you think, wow, that's mad. That couldn't possibly have happened. And that is exactly what happened to me. I had a book of world history and there was Atahualpa with Francisco Pizarro in a kind of very cool hat and a beard. And they were chatting away and they're in this room and there's this kind of piles of gold mounting up. And on the room, there is a white line that's been drawn around it. And you realize that Atulper has to get enough gold to reach that white line.
这是一种场景，也许你小时候读过世界历史书，读到这里时你会想，哇，这太疯狂了。这怎么可能发生呢？而这正是发生在我身上的事。我有一本世界历史书，上面画着阿塔瓦尔帕和弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗（Francisco Pizarro），皮萨罗戴着一顶很酷的帽子，留着胡子。他们正在聊天，身处一个房间里，周围堆满了金子。房间里画着一条白线。你意识到阿塔瓦尔帕必须筹集到足够的黄金，达到那条白线的高度。
And Dominic, I have never forgotten it because the jeopardy is immense, isn't it? Yeah. If he doesn't get enough gold to reach that white line, he's going to die. If he does get enough gold to reach that white line. Well, what then? We will find out in today's house. episode, won't we? Yeah, you're not wrong.
多米尼克，我从未忘记过这个场景，因为那种危机感太强烈了，不是吗？是的。如果他筹集不到足够的黄金达到那条白线，他就会死。如果他真的筹集到了足够的黄金达到那条白线，那又会怎样呢？我们会在今天的节目中找到答案，对吧？是的，你说得没错。
This is exactly it. I had this encyclopedia of world history as a child, maybe the same one that you did. Is it the R.J. Umsted book of world history. It probably was actually. But he wrote all history books in the 1970s. Yes. In the 1960s and 70s.
正是如此。我小时候也有一本世界历史百科全书，可能和你的是同一本。是 R.J. 昂斯特德（R.J. Umsted）的那本世界历史书吗？其实很可能就是。但他写了 20 世纪 70 年代所有的历史书。是的，在 20 世纪 60 年代和 70 年代。
So, yeah, it's a brilliant book and there was this picture and there's this bloke gesturing at the wall. Yeah. And they're filling it with kind of golden llamas and stuff like piling up. Yeah. And, you know, if he fills the room, the Spanish will let him go. This is in Carameco, where he's been taking. in prisoner. And if he doesn't fill the room, they will garota burn him or garot him. Yeah. And basically,
所以，是的，这是一本很棒的书，里面有这张图片，有个家伙正指着墙。是的。他们正在往里面填金羊驼之类的东西，堆得很高。是的。而且，你知道，如果他填满了这个房间，西班牙人就会放了他。这是在卡哈马卡（Cajamarca），他被俘虏的地方。如果他填不满这个房间，他们就会用绞刑架勒死他或烧死他。是的，基本上就是这样。
you can't wait to find out what happens next. And you know what? This really happened. And this is the story we're telling in today's episode. Brilliant. So let's remind ourselves where we've got to in the story of the Four of the Inkers. So people will remember, Francisco Pizarro and his fellow conquistadors had arrived in Kachamarka in November 1533. And they'd hold up waiting for this bloke at Tewelper, the emperor of the Inkers, who's to be fighting a civil war against his brother, Huasca. And Huascair is in a cage, isn't he, at this point? Being brought from Kusko to where Atulpa is.
你迫不及待地想知道接下来会发生什么。你知道吗？这真的发生了。这就是我们今天这集要讲的故事。太棒了。那么让我们回顾一下，我们讲到印加人故事的哪个阶段了。大家应该还记得，弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗和他的征服者同伴们于 1533 年 11 月抵达了卡哈马卡。他们驻扎在那里，等待着印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕，他当时正与他的兄弟瓦斯卡尔（Huascar）进行内战。此时瓦斯卡尔被关在笼子里，对吧？正从库斯科被押送到阿塔瓦尔帕所在的地方。
Exactly. Huasca has been taken prisoner. So Atta Welper had won the civil war, effectively. Now, Atalpa made this grand entrance to the town square, which we described last time. There's this confrontation with the Dominican friar Bithente de Balberde. And then the Spaniards charged into the square, and they took him prisoner, and they killed all his men. And we ended with this bonkers scene where he's taken in, dressed at new clothes to have dinner with Pizarro. And then to curl up with him for the night. Yeah, and then to spend the night with him.
没错。瓦斯卡尔已经被俘虏了。所以阿塔瓦尔帕实际上已经赢得了内战。现在，阿塔瓦尔帕像我们上次描述的那样，盛装进入了城镇广场。他与多米尼加修士文森特·德·瓦尔韦德（Vicente de Valverde）发生了对峙。随后西班牙人冲进广场，俘虏了他，并杀死了他所有的手下。我们结束时讲到了那个疯狂的场景：他被带进去，换上新衣服，与皮萨罗共进晚餐。然后和他蜷缩在一起过夜。是的，还要和他共度一晚。
And you suggested that Pizarro was a snorer, which would just make things even worse, wouldn't it? He's definitely a snora. Pizarro's in his 50s. He's kind of tall, he's broad, he's burly. I mean, that's a snora, definitely. Well, I think, I mean, that description applies to me as well. I don't think I'm a snorer. You're not burly.
你暗示皮萨罗是个打呼噜的人，这会让事情变得更糟，不是吗？他绝对是个打呼噜的人。皮萨罗 50 多岁了。他个子高，身材宽大，魁梧。我的意思是，那绝对是个打呼噜的人。嗯，我想，我的意思是，那个描述也适用于我。我不认为我打呼噜。你并不魁梧。
I mean, no one I call him burly if I'm. in a million years. People watching it on YouTube will be able to see that. See how Burley Tom is, exactly. So we ended with night falling, the carry and crows feasting on the bodies of the dead, and so on and so forth. And let's pick up straight away in the morning of the 17th, November, 1533.
我的意思是，如果我……一百万年内都不会有人叫我魁梧。在 YouTube 上看节目的人就能看到。看看汤姆有多魁梧，确实如此。所以我们结束时讲到夜幕降临，食腐乌鸦在死者的尸体上大快朵颐，诸如此类。让我们直接从 1533 年 11 月 17 日的早晨开始讲起。
Atta Welper wakes, and he's in a state of shock. Clearly, Pizarro has got up first without disturbing him, because he's taken in. Cup of tea. Yeah, to see Pizarro and the other Spanish captains. We found him full of fear thinking that we were going to kill him, Well, duh. Yeah.
阿塔瓦尔帕醒来时处于震惊状态。显然，皮萨罗先起床了，没有打扰他，因为他带进了一杯茶。是的，去见皮萨罗和其他西班牙船长。我们发现他充满了恐惧，以为我们要杀了他，嗯，废话。是的。
And Pizarro says to Atulpa, this is amazing thing. He says, don't be sorrowful. He says, we Christians, we've gone to many countries, we've met many mighty rulers, and one way or another, we've made them all our friends and vassals. So you shouldn't be shocked that we've captured you. I don't know whether that's any consolation. Well, I suppose it kind of is because it suggests they're not going to kill him. Well, hold on.
皮萨罗对阿塔瓦尔帕说了一件令人惊奇的事。他说，不要悲伤。他说，我们基督徒去过许多国家，见过许多强大的统治者，无论如何，我们都让他们成为了我们的朋友和附庸。所以你不应该对我们俘虏你感到震惊。我不知道这是否算是一种安慰。嗯，我想这算是一种安慰，因为它暗示他们不会杀他。嗯，等等。
If Atowalpa had said, well, who's the most famous person you've treated in this manner? And they'd say, well, Monsas, you may. At that point, his face might fall a little when he discovered the fate of the Emperor of the Aztecs. Fair point. So Atalpa says, you're going to kill me? And Pizarro says, no, no, no. We're Christians. So that means we don't kill people in cold blood. We will see in this episode how true that is.
如果阿塔瓦尔帕问，那么你用这种方式对待过的最著名的人是谁？他们会说，嗯，蒙特祖马（Montezuma）。在那一刻，当他发现阿兹特克皇帝的命运时，他的脸色可能会沉下来。有道理。所以阿塔瓦尔帕问，你们要杀我吗？皮萨罗说，不，不，不。我们是基督徒。这意味着我们不会冷血地杀人。我们会在这一集中看到这句话有多真实。
And then, I think, disastrously for the Inca's generally, Atowalpa sends a message to his army. And he says, do not flee, do not resist. Wait for my orders. I'm not dead. I'm in the power of the Christians. Later that morning, Pizarro's lieutenant Hernando de Soto, who's described as swashbuckling, or dashing. Posh. Yes, and he ends up in Arkansas or thereabouts. Looking for the Fountain of Youth.
然后，我认为对印加人来说非常灾难性的是，阿塔瓦尔帕给他的军队发了一条信息。他说，不要逃跑，不要抵抗。等待我的命令。我没死。我在基督徒的手中。那天晚些时候，皮萨罗的副手埃尔南多·德·索托（Hernando de Soto），被描述为剑客，或者说风度翩翩。时髦。是的，他最终去了阿肯色州或附近。寻找青春之泉。
Exactly. So Soto goes off to the camp of the Atalpa army, which is about 70 or 80,000 strong, supposedly. So they're outside the city. They offer no resistance when Soto turns up. They don't interfere with him at all. They just don't know what to do. They're completely bewildered.
没错。所以索托去了阿塔瓦尔帕军队的营地，据说那里有大约 7 到 8 万人。所以他们在城外。当索托出现时，他们没有进行任何抵抗。他们根本没有干扰他。他们只是不知道该怎么办。他们完全被惊呆了。
This has never happened before. These people who might as well have come from the moon have captured their emperor. They're just stunned. And actually following Atalpa's orders, which are clearly been drafted by the Spanish or interfered with by the Spanish, we're told that many of them dropped to their knees and made the sign of the cross, basically a sign of obedience to the Spaniards. So that's all great for Pizarro, even better. When Soto gets back to the town, Soto says, I found a lot of stuff in the camp and I brought it with me. 80,000 pesos worth of gold, 7,000 marks worth of silver and 14 emeralds. To quote the Spanish, the golden silver were in monstrous effigies, large and small dishes, pitchers, jugs, basins, large drinking vessels and various other pieces.
这种情况以前从未发生过。这些仿佛从月球上来的人俘虏了他们的皇帝。他们只是惊呆了。实际上，他们遵循了阿塔瓦尔帕的命令——这些命令显然是由西班牙人起草或干预的——据我们所知，他们中的许多人跪了下来，画了十字，这基本上是服从西班牙人的标志。所以这对皮萨罗来说太棒了，甚至更好。当索托回到镇上时，索托说，我在营地里发现了很多东西，我把它们带回来了。价值 8 万比索的黄金，7000 马克的白银和 14 颗祖母绿。引用西班牙人的话，这些金银是“怪异的雕像、大大小小的盘子、水罐、壶、盆、大型饮水容器和其他各种物件”。
Atta Welper said that this all came from his table service. So they've come back basically with Attawalper's crockery. And it dawns on the Spanish, I think, at this point, my God, these people place no value on golden silver other than aesthetic. It's pretty, so these guys like it, and bigwigs have it, but it has no monetary value to them, because of course the Inkers don't have money. And Atalpa sees the Spanish eyes glittering with excitement. And this gives him an idea, and this goes back to your reading at the beginning, Tom. He says, well, if you love this stuff so much, and this is my crockery, I can give you much more of
阿塔瓦尔帕说这些都来自他的餐具。所以他们基本上带回了阿塔瓦尔帕的餐具。我想，此时西班牙人意识到，天哪，这些人除了审美价值外，对金银毫无价值感。它很漂亮，所以这些人喜欢它，大人物也拥有它，但对他们来说它没有货币价值，因为印加人当然没有货币。阿塔瓦尔帕看到西班牙人眼中闪烁着兴奋的光芒。这给了他一个主意，这回到了你开头读的那段，汤姆。他说，好吧，如果你们这么喜欢这些东西，而这又是我的餐具，我可以给你们更多。
this if this means so much to you. And through these interpreters who are working for the Spanish, she says, I can give you more gold and silver than you could possibly dream of. And Pizarro says, well, how much exactly? And then this famous moment, Atta Welper, I can fill this room with gold as high as I can reach. And he sort of pretends to make a line on the wall with his hand. And the Spanish sources say, the room measured 22 feet long by 17 feet wide and it was to be filled to a white line halfway up its height, eight feet high. So in other words, as high as Atter Welper can reach. Attawelper said he would fill it with gold jars.
如果这对你们意义重大，我可以给你们更多。通过这些为西班牙人工作的翻译，他说，我可以给你们比你们梦想中更多的金银。皮萨罗问，到底有多少？然后是那个著名的时刻，阿塔瓦尔帕说，我可以把这个房间装满黄金，高到我能触及的地方。他用手在墙上比划了一条线。西班牙史料记载，房间长 22 英尺，宽 17 英尺，要填满到其高度一半的一条白线处，即 8 英尺高。换句话说，就是阿塔瓦尔帕能触及的高度。阿塔瓦尔帕说他会用金罐、
pots, tiles and other pieces. He would also fill the room twice over with silver, and he would do all this within two months. So there's a time element to this. There's a sort of elements of jeopardy. Pizarra can't believe this. And he calls in one of his secretures, a guy called Francisco de Hereth, and says, I want you to write this down, make a record. And then he says to Atuio, great, if you do this, we will let you go. We will guarantee your life. And you can go back off to your northern heartland of Quito in Ecuador. And you can be king in the north. there. And the Spanish are thinking, well, this is an amazing result. Basically, if Atta Welper can honor this, we'll get the gold. You know, because he's our prisoner and because people are bringing
壶、瓦片和其他物件填满它。他还会用白银把房间填满两次，而且他会在两个月内完成这一切。所以这里有一个时间因素。有一种危机感。皮萨罗简直不敢相信。他叫来了他的秘书之一，一个叫弗朗西斯科·德·赫雷斯（Francisco de Jerez）的人，说，我要你把它写下来，做个记录。然后他对阿塔瓦尔帕说，太好了，如果你做到这一点，我们就放了你。我们保证你的生命安全。你可以回到你位于厄瓜多尔北部的基多大本营。你可以在那里做北方的国王。西班牙人想，这真是个惊人的结果。基本上，如果阿塔瓦尔帕能兑现这个承诺，我们就能得到黄金。你知道，因为他是我们的俘虏，而且因为人们正在把
the gold, he'll be acquiescing in our overlordship. We'll turn him into our collaborator. We won't be attacked by his armies. And in the meantime, we can get reinforcements from Panama, or even from Spain. Now, this is important because Atta Welper, I think, has no sense that the Spanish are the first of many. He thinks they are brigands, raided. pirates. I don't think it ever occurs to him or indeed to any of the Inca's that more of these bearded men will come in their floating castles or whatever they call them. But I mean, that makes him sound very naive. Yeah. But you can understand why he would have no comprehension of what Europe is or any of that. Yeah. But you can see reasons why, from his point of view, this is a shrewd policy. Because firstly, it requires the Spaniards to accept that he is a legitimate heir. Yes. Because if the Spaniards are using him as their mouthpiece, it's a kind of acknowledgement that he's the rightful emperor. Also, he specified two months. It is actually going to take much longer.
黄金送来，他会默许我们的统治。我们会把他变成我们的合作者。我们不会受到他军队的攻击。与此同时，我们可以从巴拿马甚至西班牙获得增援。现在，这一点很重要，因为我认为阿塔瓦尔帕根本没有意识到西班牙人只是众多入侵者中的第一批。他认为他们是强盗、袭击者、海盗。我不认为他或任何印加人想到会有更多这样的胡子男人乘着他们的“浮动城堡”或其他什么东西到来。但我的意思是，这让他听起来很天真。是的。但你可以理解为什么他无法理解什么是欧洲，或者诸如此类的事情。是的。但你可以看出为什么从他的角度来看，这是一种精明的策略。因为首先，它要求西班牙人承认他是合法的继承人。是的。因为如果西班牙人利用他作为代言人，这在某种程度上承认他是合法的皇帝。此外，他指定了两个月。实际上这需要更长的时间。
So there's the sense that he's spinning it out. And also, if these messengers are going out, then they can communicate his wishes to his people and bring back messages to him. And also, over the process of time, he will start to target areas of the emperor. empire that he wants targeted. Because it's notable, isn't it, that he never once sends messengers up to Quito, up to his own areas. They're always going out to places that essentially, you know, he's targeted for destruction. Yeah, exactly right. He's still, I think a really important point actually that you made there is I think he is trapped by the context of the civil war intellectually. He sees everything through the prison of his struggle with Huascaar,
所以有一种他在拖延时间的感觉。而且，如果这些信使出去了，他们就可以把他的意愿传达给人民，并带回信息给他。而且，随着时间的推移，他将开始针对他想要打击的帝国区域。因为值得注意的是，不是吗，他从未派信使去基多，去他自己的领地。他们总是去那些他基本上已经指定要摧毁的地方。是的，完全正确。他仍然……我认为你刚才提到的一个非常重要的点是，我认为他在智力上被内战的背景所困。他通过与瓦斯卡尔斗争的监狱视角来看待一切，
of finishing off the civil war and then cementing his control over the empire. And the Spanish are not exactly an irritation. They're obviously more than that. But they're a factor, aren't they? Yes. They're a factor. The widest story, as he sees it, is the civil war, which he thinks the Spanish don't really understand. I think the Spanish think the civil war is an incidental detail in their big story. And we will see who's right. We will see who's right. So, the orders are sent out across the empire. Send your gold and silver to Caramaka. And in the meantime, Atalpa settles down to wait with Pizarro and the other conquistadors. And again, it is a very important. It is a very similar to the stories of Cortez and Co. with Montezuma. Their relations actually are not
结束内战，然后巩固他对帝国的控制。而西班牙人不仅仅是一种干扰。他们显然不仅仅是那样。但他们是一个因素，不是吗？是的。他们是一个因素。在他看来，更广泛的故事是内战，他认为西班牙人并不真正理解这一点。我认为西班牙人认为内战是他们宏大故事中的一个附带细节。我们将看看谁是对的。我们将看看谁是对的。所以，命令被发往帝国各地。把你们的黄金和白银送到卡哈马卡。与此同时，阿塔瓦尔帕安顿下来，与皮萨罗和其他征服者一起等待。同样，这与科尔特斯（Cortez）等人与蒙特祖马（Montezuma）的故事非常相似。他们的关系实际上并不
terrible. The Spanish are clearly fascinated by Atta Welper. They write long descriptions of him in their memoirs and chronicles and things. They're fascinated by his appearance and so on. So we know that he's probably in his early 30s. He's a big man. He's kind of an alpha male. He had a large face, handsome and fierce. His eyes reddened with blood. He spoke with much gravity. He made many lively arguments. He was a cheerful man, although unsubtle. And the unsubility is reflected in an entertaining way. So one of the conquistadors, Christobald de Mena, records that Atowalpa's favorite possession was the severed head of Atok, who was one of his brother's generals. And I quote, its teeth were closed and held a silver spout. On top of the head was attached a golden bowl.
糟糕。西班牙人显然对阿塔瓦尔帕很着迷。他们在回忆录和编年史中写了关于他的长篇描述。他们对他的外表等等很着迷。所以我们知道他可能 30 多岁。他是个大块头。他有点像个阿尔法男性。他脸很大，英俊而凶猛。他的眼睛因充血而发红。他说话非常有威严。他提出了许多生动的论点。他是个开朗的人，尽管不够细腻。这种不够细腻以一种有趣的方式反映出来。所以其中一位征服者克里斯托瓦尔·德·梅纳（Cristobal de Mena）记录说，阿塔瓦尔帕最喜欢的财产是他兄弟的一位将军阿托克（Atok）被砍下的头颅。我引用一下：“它的牙齿紧闭，含着一个银喷嘴。头顶上连着一个金碗。”
Atalpa liked to drink from it when thinking about the war against his brother, his servants pour the cheetah, that's a kind of beer made from Mays, into the bowl, and it came out through the spout. Would you drink from the severed head of one of your own? Of course you would. Yeah, I think I would. Yeah. I mean, it's actually given me quite a few ideas, though. There's some Oxford College, isn't there? Where they, it turned out recently, I wrote a column about it in the times. It turned out that they were drinking after senior common room dinners or something. They were drinking from the severed head of somebody that had been given to the college. Did you see this? I didn't. It was a skull. And if you've got a skull, you might as well use it. Do you know what? I'm going to look this up. I'm going to do some live research. Has it been sent back for dignified burial? Professor Dan Hicks, I think. Of course. Yes. He'd be very against that. Yeah, woke professor campaigned against it.
阿塔瓦尔帕在思考与他兄弟的战争时喜欢从里面喝酒，他的仆人把“奇查”（一种用玉米酿造的啤酒）倒进碗里，它就从喷嘴里流出来。你会从你自己的一个人的断头里喝酒吗？当然会。是的，我想我会。我的意思是，它实际上给了我不少想法。牛津大学有某个学院，不是吗？最近发现，我在《泰晤士报》上写过一篇专栏文章。事实证明，他们在高级公共休息室晚餐后喝酒。他们从一个被送给学院的人的断头里喝酒。你看到了吗？我没看到。那是一个头骨。如果你有一个头骨，你最好利用它。你知道吗？我要查一下。我要做一些现场研究。它被送回去进行尊严安葬了吗？丹·希克斯（Dan Hicks）教授，我想。当然。是的。他会非常反对那样。是的，觉醒派教授发起了反对运动。
Worcester College. And I wrote a column for the Times with the excellent headline, drinking from skulls is a noble tradition. Well, it is. It clearly is. It clearly is. And Atulper is, you know, part of a proud Latin American. American tradition. He is. And he's a bright fellow because actually we learned that one of the Spanish conquistos said he's the most educated and capable Indian that's ever been seen to such an extent that he plays chess very well. So they taught him chess. Yeah. He sounds like a
伍斯特学院（Worcester College）。我为《泰晤士报》写了一篇专栏文章，标题非常出色：“从头骨中饮酒是一种高贵的传统”。嗯，确实是。这显然是。这显然是。阿塔瓦尔帕是，你知道，一个骄傲的拉丁美洲传统的一部分。他是。而且他是个聪明人，因为实际上我们了解到其中一位西班牙征服者说他是“所见过的最有教养和能力的印第安人，以至于他下棋下得非常好”。所以他们教他下棋。是的。他听起来像个
tremendous companion. So Francisco Pizarro's page, who was a cousin of his, a teenager called Pedro, he wrote down an account of Atalpa's daily rituals, which is actually really interesting. Atowap would sit on this little stool and he was always attended by beautiful young women. They would bring him his food in golden bowls. He'd point at what he wanted. And then they would feed him with their bare hands. And if he wanted to spit afterwards, he would spit into their hands and they would kind of hold out their copped hands. I mean, I think he's a kind of model for relaxed lifestyle. Yeah. Live your life, the Inca Way. Yeah. Inca Lounge Corps. Well, so talking of Inca lounge wear, he has some interesting fashion material.
了不起的同伴。所以弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗的侍从，他的一个表亲，一个十几岁的少年叫佩德罗，他写下了阿塔瓦尔帕日常仪式的记录，这实际上非常有趣。阿塔瓦尔帕会坐在那个小凳子上，总是由美丽的年轻女子侍奉。她们会用金碗给他端上食物。他会指着他想要的东西。然后她们会用赤手喂他。如果他之后想吐痰，他会吐在她们的手里，她们会伸出她们合拢的手。我的意思是，我认为他是放松生活方式的典范。是的。过你的生活，印加方式。是的。印加休闲装。好吧，说到印加休闲装，他有一些有趣的时尚材料。
He has these lovely soft tunics and robes made from the skin of vampire bats. You do wonder whether Spanish is slightly exaggerating here, but then there's this nice detail. So when he's worn anything or when he's eaten anything, they gather everything up. And this includes basically the stuff that he's spat out and also even the sort of rushes that have been placed on the floor under his feet. And they put them in a special leather chest. And Pedro said, I asked why they kept all this. They told me it was in order to burn it. Anything touched by the ruler, the son of the sun,
他有这些可爱的柔软束腰外衣和长袍，是用吸血蝙蝠的皮制成的。你确实会怀疑西班牙人在这里是否稍微夸张了，但随后有这个不错的细节。所以当他穿过任何东西或吃过任何东西时，他们会把所有东西收集起来。这基本上包括他吐出来的东西，甚至包括放在他脚下的地板上的灯芯草。他们把它们放在一个特殊的皮箱里。佩德罗说，我问为什么要保留所有这些。他们告诉我这是为了烧掉它。任何被统治者、太阳之子触碰过的东西，
was reduced to ashes and thrown to the winds since no one else was allowed to touch it. I mean, even by the standards of Spanish royalty, you thought that was excessive. But it goes to a very important point. Something is very useful to the Spaniards, the absolute authority of the Sapa Inca, because by becoming Sapa Inca,
都被化为灰烬并随风而去，因为不允许其他人触碰它。我的意思是，即使按照西班牙皇室的标准，你也会认为这太过分了。但这触及了一个非常重要的点。对西班牙人来说，萨帕·印加（Sapa Inca）的绝对权威非常有用，因为通过成为萨帕·印加，
you effectively become, are you a god, you're kind of adjacent to a god, I suppose. You're an intermediary between the dimensions of the earthly and the supernatural. Dominic, to coin a phrase. Exactly, like the great speaker of Tenoste-Lan, Montezuma, had been in exactly the same position. There's no other real source of authority. And this means that basically the Spaniards now control the only source of authority, unless you're one of the Chwaska faction,
你实际上成为了，你是神吗，我想你有点接近神。多米尼克，用一句流行语来说，你是尘世维度和超自然维度之间的中介。没错。就像特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan）的伟大演说家蒙特祖马一样，他处于完全相同的位置。没有其他真正的权威来源。这意味着基本上西班牙人现在控制了唯一的权威来源，除非你是瓦斯卡尔派系的人，
the only source of authority between Ecuador and northern Chile. And it means it's very hard for somebody else to challenge them. Effectively, the Inca's 12 million people maybe are completely leaderless. with Atuelper as a prisoner. And the Spanish used this to their advantage. So as they did in Mexico, they allow him to receive, as you mentioned, to receive messengers,
这是厄瓜多尔和智利北部之间唯一的权威来源。这意味着其他人很难挑战他们。实际上，印加人的 1200 万人口可能完全没有领导者，因为阿塔瓦尔帕被俘了。西班牙人利用这一点为自己谋利。所以就像他们在墨西哥所做的那样，他们允许他接收，正如你提到的，接收信使，
to receive tribute. They let his advisors come and go. So these blokes turn up with these massive ear spools in their ears and, you know, all of this. Dominic, I mean, we're not the rest is ants, are we?
接收贡品。他们让他的顾问来来去去。所以这些家伙带着这些巨大的耳轴出现在耳朵里，你知道，所有这些。多米尼克，我的意思是，我们不是切叶蚁，对吧？
No, never pretended to be. I think there's a parasitic ant that will invade a rival ant colony and will take captive the head of the ants. Either kill it or whatever. And then just take over the whole ant-eat, locks and broken barrel. So there's maybe a kind of parallel between the Spanish and parasitic ants. That's a very compelling natural history parallel.
不，从来没假装是。我想有一种寄生蚁会入侵竞争对手的蚁群，并俘虏蚂蚁的首领。要么杀死它，要么怎样。然后接管整个蚁丘，彻底接管。所以西班牙人和寄生蚁之间可能有一种相似之处。这是一个非常引人注目的自然历史类比。
Well done. I enjoyed that. It was worth the five-minute break in recording to Google that. Yeah, but I knew what to Google, right? You did. You deserve all the credit. And it's the kind of thing that goes on in the rainforests of South America. Yes, to the sound of the pan pipes, surely.
干得好。我很喜欢。为了谷歌搜索那个，录音中断五分钟是值得的。是的，但我知道该谷歌搜索什么，对吧？你确实知道。你理应获得所有赞誉。而且这是在南美洲雨林中发生的那种事情。是的，伴随着排箫的声音，肯定是的。
So even Atalpa's generals, because don't forget there's been civil war, even his generals act as though nothing has changed. It's important for people to realize there are the various armies roaming around. So two of Atalpa's key generals who will play a part in the next couple of episodes are in the south. There's a guy with the excellent name of Kiskees, who has just captured Kusko. And there's another commander, basically the commander-in-chief, the oldest of the commanders, who's called Chalkuchima. and Chalko Chalcachima is midway between Kusko and Kahamaka. And both of these guys have about, I don't know, 40,000 men or something. Now there's a third general who we don't need to worry about right now called Ruminiawi,
所以即使是阿塔瓦尔帕的将军们，因为别忘了已经发生了内战，即使是他的将军们也表现得好像什么都没变。人们意识到有各种军队在四处游荡是很重要的。所以阿塔瓦尔帕的两名关键将军，他们将在接下来的几集中发挥作用，都在南方。有一个名字很棒的家伙叫基斯基斯（Kiskees），他刚刚占领了库斯科。还有另一位指挥官，基本上是总司令，最年长的指挥官，叫查尔库奇马（Chalcuchima），查尔库奇马在库斯科和卡哈马卡之间。这两个家伙都有大约，我不知道，4 万人左右。现在有第三位将军，我们现在不需要担心，叫鲁米尼亚维（Ruminiawi），
who is much further north. He's in Quito in the kind of home base of the Attawalpa side of the Civil War divide. Atalpa says to these three generals, stay where you are. Don't interfere with the ransom. Wait for it to be collected. The foreigners will go once the ransom is spent. paid, and we can get on with the business of finishing off the war, killing on our enemies, and cementing control of the empire. The question, I suppose, is would his generals have tried to
他在更北边。他在基多，在内战分裂的阿塔瓦尔帕一方的大本营。阿塔瓦尔帕对这三位将军说，待在你们的地方。不要干扰赎金。等待它被收集。外国人一旦赎金支付就会离开，我们可以继续结束战争、杀死我们的敌人并巩固对帝国的控制。我想问题是，他的将军们是否会尝试
rescue him anyway? And I would guess probably not, because they are so, everybody is so disorientated and baffled. In his brilliant book, The Conquest of the Inca's, John Hemming makes the excellent point that basically, in most places the Europeans conquered, Europeans had arrived multiple times before they actually turned up for good. You know, missionaries had come, traders, envoys. What's very unusual about the conquest of Peru is basically the Spanish do it all in one go. So these generals have literally never seen a European.
无论如何都要救他？我猜可能不会，因为他们太，每个人都太迷失方向和困惑了。在约翰·赫明（John Hemming）那本出色的《印加人的征服》（The Conquest of the Incas）中，他提出了一个极好的观点，即基本上，在欧洲人征服的大多数地方，欧洲人在他们真正永久定居之前已经多次到达过。你知道，传教士来过，商人，特使。秘鲁征服非常不寻常的一点是，基本上西班牙人一次性完成了所有事情。所以这些将军们真的从未见过欧洲人。
They've never heard of a European. Until they hear some mad guys with beards have turned up and captured the emperor, they didn't even know Europe existed. But what do you think they find more disorientating? The fact that Europeans have turned up with beards and stuff. Yeah. Or the fact that they have dared to seize the emperor and keep him as a hostage.
他们从未听说过欧洲人。直到他们听说一些留着胡子的疯子出现了并俘虏了皇帝，他们甚至不知道欧洲存在。但你认为他们觉得什么更令人迷失方向？欧洲人留着胡子出现等等。是的。还是他们竟然敢抓住皇帝并把他作为人质。
Because in a sense, that must be the thing that's really destabilizing. Because there's nothing in their history or their ideology or their experience that would enable them to know what to do in such a scenario. As we will see, they didn't even look the emperor in the eye. The emperor doesn't meet their eye when he talks to them. So the idea that these guys will have laid hands on him, dragged him out of his litter, and then forced him to sleep next to them. that's surely the biggest twist of all. Now, you mentioned that Huasca was being brought north underguard. In a cage, yes.
因为在某种意义上，那一定是非常不稳定的事情。因为在他们的历史、意识形态或经验中，没有任何东西能让他们知道在这种情况下该怎么办。正如我们将看到的，他们甚至没有直视皇帝。皇帝在和他们说话时没有与他们对视。所以这些人竟然对他下手，把他从轿子里拖出来，然后强迫他睡在他们旁边。那肯定是最令人震惊的转折。现在，你提到瓦斯卡尔在守卫下被带往北方。在笼子里，是的。
So Pizarro, when Attaualpa tells him this, Pizarro says, do not harm your brother, because Pizarro obviously thinks, wow. If I get both of them, you can make them fight. Well, we sleep with one on each side. Who knows? But Atowalpa has no intention of allowing his brother to fall into the Spanish hands, because, of course, he worries that they might prefer his brother. So he sends orders to the people who are bringing Huascar up at a place called Andamaka,
所以皮萨罗，当阿塔瓦尔帕告诉他这一点时，皮萨罗说，不要伤害你的兄弟，因为皮萨罗显然想，哇。如果我把他们两个都抓到，你可以让他们打架。好吧，我们一边睡一个。谁知道呢？但阿塔瓦尔帕无意让他的兄弟落入西班牙人之手，因为当然，他担心他们可能会更喜欢他的兄弟。所以他向在安达马卡（Andamaka）押送瓦斯卡尔的人发出了命令，
which is south of Cayamaka in the mountains. Huasca is murdered by his guards and his body is thrown into the river. So that's a great example of how Atulper, even as a captive, is still able effectively to rule the empire because all these messengers are going out, taking his commands. Exactly right. And it's also a good example of how Atowalper is not this sort of martyr, saintly martyr. Attaelper is a very hard man.
那是在卡哈马卡南部的山区。瓦斯卡尔被他的守卫谋杀，尸体被扔进了河里。所以这是一个很好的例子，说明阿塔瓦尔帕即使作为俘虏，仍然能够有效地统治帝国，因为所有这些信使都在出去，执行他的命令。完全正确。这也是一个很好的例子，说明阿塔瓦尔帕不是那种殉道者，圣洁的殉道者。阿塔瓦尔帕是一个非常强硬的人。
No, I think we've established he's not a saintly martyr. So Atta alpa sends orders, carry on with the hits, basically. So some of his other half-brothers, some of his other relatives knocked off in the next few weeks. And to us, to subsequent historians, they say, isn't this insane? That Attaalper is still pursuing his crazy factionalism after he's been taken prisoner in the face of this existential foreign threat. But he doesn't think it is an existential foreign threat. He thinks the civil war is the priority, and hopefully in the long run, he thinks maybe he could turn this to his advantage. But I think also in a civil war, perhaps you hate the people you're fighting much more than you do foreign intruders.
不，我想我们已经确定他不是一个圣洁的殉道者。所以阿塔瓦尔帕发出命令，基本上继续进行打击。所以他的一些其他同父异母的兄弟，他的一些其他亲戚在接下来的几周里被干掉了。对于我们，对于后来的历史学家，他们说，这不是很疯狂吗？阿塔瓦尔帕在面对这种生存性的外国威胁时，在被俘后仍在追求他疯狂的派系斗争。但他不认为这是生存性的外国威胁。他认为内战是优先事项，而且他希望从长远来看，他认为也许他可以利用这一点为自己谋利。但我认为在内战中，也许你恨你正在与之战斗的人比恨外国入侵者要多得多。
Yeah, I don't think he hates the Spanish. I think he's completely confused by them. So let's move on a few weeks to January 1533. The treasure is now arriving in Cayamaca. So that's jugs, plates, bowls, all these things made of gold. And the Spanish start breaking them up when they arrive so they can fit more and more in the room. they want to cram it into the room. Attawalpa says to them, what are you doing? Why are you doing that? I will give you so much gold. You'll be sated with it. But some of the Spanish say, you know, a few weeks that gone by, mate, we haven't seen as much gold as we hoped. So Atalpa says, well, I can tell you two places in particular where you'll get gold. And there are two of the most sacred temples in the empire.
是的，我不认为他恨西班牙人。我认为他完全被他们搞糊涂了。所以让我们快进几周到 1533 年 1 月。宝藏现在正在抵达卡哈马卡。所以那是金子做的壶、盘子、碗，所有这些东西。西班牙人开始在它们到达时把它们拆开，这样他们就可以在房间里装下更多。他们想把它塞进房间里。阿塔瓦尔帕对他们说，你们在做什么？你们为什么要那样做？我会给你们这么多黄金。你们会对此感到满足的。但一些西班牙人说，你知道，几周过去了，伙计，我们没有看到我们希望看到的那么多黄金。所以阿塔瓦尔帕说，好吧，我可以告诉你们两个特别的地方，你们会得到黄金。那是帝国中最神圣的两座神庙。
So one of them is the shrine and oracle of Pachacamac, which is near the coast, near what's now Lima. And the other is the sun temple of Kori Kancha in Kusko. I think both of these, you mentioned, Tom, in your excellent Christopher Plummer reading. And the reason Attaualpa wants to surrender these two places in particular goes back to the point about the Civil War. So Cusco, the Sun Temple there, the most famous temple and religious site in the Andean world. Why does you want to surrender that? Because he's probably never even been to Cusco. Cusco is his brother's city, his brother's heartland. Well, he was planning to wipe Cusco out, wasn't he? Yeah, exactly. So get the Spanish to do it for him. Yeah. He represents the north of this empire. not the South, and he just thinks, well, you know, this is a brilliant way of punishing Kusko for backing my brother.
其中之一是帕查卡马克（Pachacamac）的神殿和神谕，它靠近海岸，靠近现在的利马。另一个是库斯科的科里坎查（Kori Kancha）太阳神庙。我想这两个，你提到的，汤姆，在你出色的克里斯托弗·普卢默的朗读中。阿塔瓦尔帕想要交出这两个地方的原因特别回到了关于内战的那一点。所以库斯科，那里的太阳神庙，安第斯世界最著名的神庙和宗教场所。他为什么要交出那个？因为他可能从来没去过库斯科。库斯科是他兄弟的城市，他兄弟的大本营。嗯，他正计划消灭库斯科，不是吗？是的，完全正确。所以让西班牙人替他做。是的。他代表了这个帝国的北方，而不是南方，他只是想，好吧，你知道，这是一个惩罚库斯科支持我兄弟的绝妙方法。
Yeah. I mean, it's like someone in Manchester saying, destroy London. Exactly. And then the other one, Patrick Amac, amusingly, the priests at this Oracle had made some disastrous predictions. They had they basically had the crystal ball that I used to use in my associated newspaper stays. So they said, first of all, they had said that his father, Hwena Kappak, would recover of smallpox. He promptly died. They told Huascaa that he would beat Atta Welper, as we've discovered, Huasca ended up in a cage, and they told Atta Welper that foreigners would arrive and he would easily defeat them. So Huatu Elper says, this oracle is absolutely useless. And actually, there's a funny story. The high priest apparently went of Patrick Kamak,
是的。我的意思是，这就像曼彻斯特有人说，摧毁伦敦。完全正确。然后另一个，帕查卡马克，有趣的是，这个神谕的祭司们做出了一些灾难性的预测。他们基本上拥有我在《联合报》时期使用的水晶球。所以他们说，首先，他们说他的父亲，瓦伊纳·卡帕克（Huayna Capac），会从天花中康复。他很快就死了。他们告诉瓦斯卡尔他会打败阿塔瓦尔帕，正如我们发现的那样，瓦斯卡尔最终被关进了笼子，他们告诉阿塔瓦尔帕外国人会到来，他会轻易打败他们。所以阿塔瓦尔帕说，这个神谕完全没用。而且实际上，有一个有趣的故事。帕查卡马克的大祭司显然去了
went to Caiy Mark to see Atta Welper. And Atta Welper upbraided him in front of the Spanids and said, your predictions are terrible. You know, you're absolutely worthless. Of course I'm going to take all your gold. You've absolutely shamed yourselves. But also, Atulpa has started to fathom Spaniard's religious motivation. And he kind of fires them up for sacking these temples by saying that the gods worship there are demons. Yes, exactly. So that's another way in which he can get his vengeance on kind of priesthoods that he feel are against his rule. And actually, the interesting thing, so Patrick Kamak, Patrick Kamak dates back for more than a thousand years before the Inca's.
卡哈马卡见阿塔瓦尔帕。阿塔瓦尔帕在西班牙人面前责骂他，说，你的预测太糟糕了。你知道，你完全一文不值。我当然要拿走你所有的黄金。你们完全丢尽了脸。但阿塔瓦尔帕也开始理解西班牙人的宗教动机。他通过说那里崇拜的神是恶魔，煽动他们洗劫这些神庙。是的，完全正确。所以这是他可以向他认为反对他统治的祭司阶层复仇的另一种方式。而且实际上，有趣的是，帕查卡马克，帕查卡马克可以追溯到印加人之前一千多年。
This is not an Inca shrine. It's part of the Andean world, but it's not part of their official. state-sponsored sun religion, which they've been really trying to impose across the empire in recent decades. There's a slight kind of owlman quality to it as well, isn't there? So the owl man is the figure in the Aztec story where you unleash the owl man and the world will end, but at least you'll destroy your enemies and he gets shot and that's the end of the owlman. There's a prophecy that if the temple at Patrick Khamak is attacked, then a universal flood will wipe out the entire world.
这不是一座印加神庙。它是安第斯世界的一部分，但不是他们官方的、国家支持的太阳宗教的一部分，这是他们近几十年来一直试图在帝国各地强加的。它也有一种轻微的“猫头鹰人”特质，不是吗？所以猫头鹰人是阿兹特克故事中的人物，在那里你释放猫头鹰人，世界就会终结，但至少你会摧毁你的敌人，他被枪杀了，这就是猫头鹰人的结局。有一个预言说，如果帕查卡马克的神庙受到攻击，那么一场全球洪水将消灭整个世界。
That's right, yes. And therefore, if tribute isn't paid to this temple, then it will be disastrous. So essentially, the Spanish, by sending people to loot it, are putting that prophecy to the test. And if they're wrong, then a universal flood will destroy all of life on Earth. So the stakes are quite high. They are high. So Pizarro sends his brother, Hernando, to this shrine at Patrick Hammack on the coast. And it's good for us that he did, because some of the guys that went with,
没错，是的。因此，如果不向这座神庙支付贡品，那么这将是灾难性的。所以基本上，西班牙人通过派人去洗劫它，是在考验那个预言。如果他们错了，那么一场全球洪水将摧毁地球上所有的生命。所以赌注相当高。它们很高。所以皮萨罗派他的兄弟埃尔南多去海岸上的帕查卡马克神殿。他这样做对我们有好处，因为一些随行的人，
Fernando wrote these fantastic memoirs of the conquest. So a guy called Miguel de Estete. And they write these really, there's some of the first kind of really lyrical descriptions of the South American landscape. There's a brilliant description of the road over the Andes. And the highlands are described as truly a land so muddy that it's like has not been seen in Christendom. They obviously not been to Somerset in January. No, clearly not. So they go to the sanctuary and Estate said it was basically the top of an adobe pyramid and he was very underwhelmed by it.
埃尔南多写了这些关于征服的精彩回忆录。所以一个叫米格尔·德·埃斯特特（Miguel de Estete）的家伙。他们写了这些真的，有一些是关于南美景观的第一批真正抒情的描述。有一段关于安第斯山脉道路的精彩描述。高地被描述为“确实是一片如此泥泞的土地，在基督教世界中从未见过”。他们显然没在 1 月份去过萨默塞特。不，显然没有。所以他们去了圣所，埃斯特特说它基本上是一个土坯金字塔的顶部，他对此非常失望。
He said, it was very dark and it didn't smell very pleasant, a very small, rough cavern. Seeing the filth and mockery of the idol, we went out to ask why they thought highly of something so dirty and ugly. And actually, there was no treasure there at all. If there was any treasure, the priests had hidden it.
他说，它非常黑暗，闻起来不太好，是一个非常小、粗糙的洞穴。看到偶像的污秽和嘲弄，我们出去问为什么他们认为如此肮脏和丑陋的东西很高贵。而且实际上，那里根本没有宝藏。如果有任何宝藏，祭司们已经把它藏起来了。
And the Spanish, they just smashed the whole place up. And is there a universal flood? No, not at all. So, so, Anand, then sets off back to Kayamaka and actually the distances in this story are absolutely mad. So Anando has just travelled 800 miles
西班牙人，他们只是把整个地方砸烂了。有全球洪水吗？不，根本没有。所以，埃尔南多然后出发回卡哈马卡，实际上这个故事中的距离简直太疯狂了。所以埃尔南多刚刚走了 800 英里，
he's got 800 miles to go back and he goes, he's going back to Kahamaka and then he discovers that at a place called Shaoosa. Attawalpa's commander-in-chief, this guy, Chalcuchima, is blocking the mountain road with about 35,000 men. Now, Chalka Chima
他还有 800 英里要走回去，他要去卡哈马卡，然后他发现在一个叫绍萨（Jauja）的地方。阿塔瓦尔帕的总司令，这个家伙，查尔库奇马，正带着大约 3.5 万人封锁山路。现在，查尔库奇马
is the most experienced of all Atta-Walpa's generals. He's basically the sort of the grizzled veteran character in a sort of fantasy novel or something. I served your father. You know, that kind of thing. Yes. That's his vibe.
是阿塔瓦尔帕所有将军中最有经验的。他基本上是某种奇幻小说中那种饱经风霜的老兵角色。我侍奉过你的父亲。你知道，那种感觉。是的。这就是他的氛围。
So the kind of character who is honorable, but ultimately doomed, would you say, in a science fiction story. Completely. That's completely what he is. Exactly right. So he's like that sort of Jora, Mormont or whatever, in Game of Thrones, that sort of figure. Yeah. So John Heming says, Child Kuchima is the one man who might have united the empire
所以那种在科幻小说中，虽然光荣但最终注定失败的角色，你会这么说吗？完全是。他完全就是那样。完全正确。所以他就像《权力的游戏》中的乔拉·莫尔蒙（Jorah Mormont）之类的角色。是的。所以约翰·赫明说，查尔库奇马是唯一一个可能团结帝国
against the Spaniards because he's the one man who's not entirely defined by the Civil War because he had served Atta Welper's father. So in other words, what Chalcachima does now is very important. Anando arrives in Chowja with his men. They've done this mad journey. They've climbed 16,000 feet up into the Andes. They've been trudging through snow. They're absolutely shattered.
对抗西班牙人的人，因为他是唯一一个不完全被内战定义的人，因为他曾侍奉过阿塔瓦尔帕的父亲。换句话说，查尔库奇马现在所做的事情非常重要。埃尔南多带着他的人抵达了绍萨。他们完成了这趟疯狂的旅程。他们爬上了安第斯山脉 16000 英尺高的地方。他们一直在雪中跋涉。他们完全精疲力竭。
There are only a few dozen of them, and Chalcuchima has more than 30,000 men. They arrive in Jowja and there's this festival going on. So there's people dancing and singing, and they sort of ignore the Spanish. So the Spanish hang around a bit and then finally Chalcachima arrives with his senior officers. We have a description of him from the later chronicler, Thea Theta de Leon, who says he was a muscular man with a broad back, a fierce expression and a short, very thick neck. So he looks like a rugby player, basically. Anando says to Chalcuchima, you know, Atualpa wants you to come with us to Chayamaka. And Chalcuchima says, no, no, what, I'm not going with you. I haven't had any orders
他们只有几十个人，而查尔库奇马（Chalcuchima）有三万多名士兵。他们抵达豪哈（Jowja）时，那里正在举行节日庆典。人们载歌载舞，几乎无视了西班牙人。西班牙人在那里逗留了一会儿，最后查尔库奇马带着他的高级军官们到了。后来的编年史家西耶萨·德·莱昂（Cieza de León）对他的描述是：他身材魁梧，背部宽阔，表情凶猛，脖子又短又粗。基本上，他看起来就像个橄榄球运动员。埃尔南多（Hernando）对查尔库奇马说，你知道，阿塔瓦尔帕（Atahualpa）希望你和我们一起去卡哈马卡（Cajamarca）。查尔库奇马说，不，不，什么？我才不跟你们走。我没有接到任何命令
to say I should go with you. They have a massive argument all night. The Spanish think, well, if he doesn't, if he attacks us, we're pretty much doomed. Because he's got 30,000 men and we've got sort of, you know, 20 men or something. But the mad thing is, when the dawn breaks, Chalko Chima returns and says, yeah, actually, I've been thinking about it. I will come with you, to Kai Marka. Fair enough. One possible influence on him, do you think, is the fact that the local people here are anti-Awaalpa. Yes. So they had not been backing them. And these are the wanker people. Do you know, I actually, I admitted all mention of these people.
说我应该跟你们走。他们整晚都在激烈争吵。西班牙人想，如果他不走，如果他攻击我们，我们基本上就死定了。因为他有三万大军，而我们只有二十个人左右。但疯狂的是，当黎明破晓时，查尔库奇马回来了，说，好吧，其实我考虑过了。我会和你们一起去卡哈马卡。好吧。你认为对他产生影响的一个可能因素是，当地人反感阿塔瓦尔帕吗？是的。所以他们一直没有支持他。这些人是万卡（Huanca）人。你知道吗，我其实删掉了所有关于这些人的提及。
The wanker. For precisely this reason, because I thought you would get too much. How did it find it funny at all? Schoolboyish pleasure from the existence of these people. There's nothing funny about it. But I think the role of the wanker in this story is one that, you know, we shouldn't overlook. No, I mean, and indeed in this podcast, we shouldn't overlook it at all. Because the wankers will be back, won't they later on?
万卡人。正是因为这个原因，因为我觉得你会觉得太多了。你怎么会觉得这很有趣？因为这些人的存在而产生一种小学生般的快感。这没什么好笑的。但我认为万卡人在这个故事中的角色，你知道，我们不应该忽视。不，我的意思是，事实上在这个播客里，我们根本不应该忽视它。因为万卡人还会回来的，不是吗，稍后？
Yeah, well, they will. I mean, I was hoping they won't, but clearly you're going to bring them back in. It's all about detail, Dominic. It's about the granular level. So anyway, why has Chalkechima? He hasn't just done it because of the presence of the Huanka. He's also going with them, I think, because he's being completely thrown by the Spaniard's presence,
是的，他们会回来的。我的意思是，我希望他们不会，但显然你会把他们带回来。这全在于细节，多米尼克。这在于颗粒度。所以不管怎样，为什么查尔库奇马会这样？他不仅仅是因为万卡人的存在才这么做。我认为他跟着他们走，也是因为他被西班牙人的存在彻底搞糊涂了，
by their very existence. He doesn't know what to do. When they say Atta Welper has sent for you, I mean, he's taking a risk if he doesn't go. So he decides he'll go with them. And as John Heming says, this decision was a tragic mistake, one of the turning points in the collapse of resistance
被他们本身的存在所困扰。他不知道该怎么办。当他们说阿塔瓦尔帕传唤你时，我的意思是，如果他不走，他就是在冒险。所以他决定和他们一起走。正如约翰·海明（John Hemming）所说，这个决定是一个悲剧性的错误，是抵抗力量崩溃的转折点之一
the Spanish invaders. For by riding out of Shausha with this deceptively small band of strangers, Chalcuchima delivered himself into captivity and death. Oh dear. But not at first. So at first they treat him with tremendous friendship and they ride together across the great scenery of the Cordillera Blanca, past the sources of the Amazon or this kind of thing and they finally get to Chayamaka. And the other Spaniards say, oh, brilliant, you're back. Great to see you. Chalcichima at this point probably is beginning to think, did I make the right choice in going with these guys? Because they take him into Seattle, Welper. Child Kachima is overcome with emotion to see the great Inca.
西班牙入侵者。因为查尔库奇马带着这群少得离谱的陌生人骑马离开豪哈，就把自己送进了囚禁和死亡之中。噢，天哪。但起初并非如此。起初，他们对他表现出极大的友谊，他们一起骑马穿过布兰卡山脉（Cordillera Blanca）的壮丽景色，经过亚马逊河的源头之类的地方，最后到达了卡哈马卡。其他西班牙人说，哦，太棒了，你回来了。很高兴见到你。查尔库奇马此时可能开始想，我跟着这些人走，选择对吗？因为他们把他带到了阿塔瓦尔帕面前。查尔库奇马见到伟大的印加王，激动得热泪盈眶。
And he, and I quote, raised his hands to the son to give thanks for being allowed to see him again. He went up to him with great reverence, weeping and kissed him on the face, hands and feet. And the other chiefs who had come with him did the same. But Atalpa won't even look him in the face. Now, this is standard for the Inca. The Inca doesn't normally look at commoners in the eyes, but the Spanish. can see that Atta Welper is gutted, that his best commander has just walked straight into captivity alongside him.
他，我引用一下，举起双手向太阳致谢，感谢能再次见到他。他怀着极大的敬意走到他面前，哭泣着亲吻他的脸、手和脚。随他而来的其他酋长也做了同样的事。但阿塔瓦尔帕甚至不看他的脸。现在，这对印加人来说是标准的。印加王通常不会直视平民的眼睛，但西班牙人能看出阿塔瓦尔帕心碎了，他最好的指挥官刚刚和他一起直接走进了囚笼。
And actually, now for Chalguchima, the smiles on the faces of his Spanish friends begin to fade. It is odd that Attawalpa didn't send him a message and say, don't do it. It's hard when you're communicating only by knotted, knotted strings, no? Yeah, I suppose. I mean, this is the issue if they develop writing and maybe a different story. So the Spanish now say to Chalcuchima, right, you know, the gloves are off now. Where's your gold?
事实上，现在对于查尔库奇马来说，他那些西班牙朋友脸上的笑容开始消失了。奇怪的是，阿塔瓦尔帕没有给他传个口信说，别这么做。当你只能通过打结的绳子交流时，这很难，不是吗？是的，我想也是。我的意思是，如果他们发明了文字，也许故事会不同。所以西班牙人现在对查尔库奇马说，好了，你知道，现在不客气了。你的黄金在哪里？
We would like more of your gold. And Chalcichima said, I don't have any, I mean, what gold I have I brought with me. Soto, and we told, took him aside and threatened to burn him unless he told the truth. He gave the same answer as before. They put up a steak and tied him to it and brought firewood and straw, saying they would set fire to him unless he told the truth. Then there's this terrible scene. Chalko Chalcima kind of breaks down. And he says, get the emperor.
我们想要你更多的黄金。查尔库奇马说，我没有，我的意思是，我有什么黄金就带了什么。索托（Soto）把我们带到一边，威胁要烧死他，除非他说实话。他给出了和之前一样的回答。他们竖起一根木桩，把他绑在上面，拿来柴火和稻草，说如果他不讲真话，就会放火烧他。然后发生了这可怕的一幕。查尔库奇马崩溃了。他说，把皇帝带过来。
They bring out the emperor. Atta whelper comes out and says, don't worry, don't listen to these Spanish. They're bluffing. They won't burn you. Spanish promptly set him on fire. And we're told... Gusts of laughter.
他们带出了皇帝。阿塔瓦尔帕出来说，别担心，别听这些西班牙人的。他们在虚张声势。他们不会烧死你的。西班牙人立刻点火烧了他。我们被告知……一阵阵笑声。
Yeah. They cut him down after a few moments. And they dragged him to Anando Pizarro's lodging. So this is the bloke who's been travelling with him. Quote, his legs and arms burned and his tendons shriveled. And we're told that Anando was quite nice to him and tended him. I mean, this is a skill. It turns out the Spaniards have, isn't it?
是的。片刻之后，他们把他放了下来。他们把他拖到埃尔南多·皮萨罗（Hernando Pizarro）的住处。所以这就是那个一直和他一起旅行的家伙。引用：他的腿和手臂被烧焦，肌腱萎缩。我们被告知埃尔南多对他还不错，照顾了他。我的意思是，这是一种技能。事实证明西班牙人有这种技能，不是吗？
is burning human bodies to just the right degree. Exactly. I like grilling. He's not dead, but I have to tell you that for Chalkajima, and indeed for Atta Welper, there is not going to be a very happy ending. So I think on that note, we should take a break. There is so much to play for, and we will find out who triumphs, the Spaniards, or Atta Welper after the break. This episode is brought to you by Claude, by Anthropic. Now, history lives in the contradictions.
就是把人体烧到恰到好处的程度。没错。我喜欢烧烤。他还没死，但我必须告诉你，对于查尔库奇马，甚至对于阿塔瓦尔帕来说，结局都不会太幸福。所以我想以此为契机，我们休息一下。还有很多值得期待的内容，休息过后，我们将揭晓谁会获胜，是西班牙人，还是阿塔瓦尔帕。本集由 Anthropic 公司的 Claude 赞助。历史存在于矛盾之中。
Yeah, I've always been fascinated by the great mysteries of history. Like what happened to the Maya civilization of Central America? Why were all those great cities deserted? But Tom, there's one mystery that's always fascinated you, isn't there? Yes, Dominic, I've always been fascinated by the question of how humans came to make and use fire. How did that originate? and a tremendous discovery was announced just last year that the place where it seems fire was invented was Suffolk. Well, you know, one of the things that makes history so fascinating is the kind of back and forth between sources to try and explain these great mysteries. And you know what's built for that kind of thinking? Claude is built for that way of thinking.
是的，我一直对历史上的伟大谜团着迷。比如中美洲的玛雅文明发生了什么？为什么那些伟大的城市都被遗弃了？但是汤姆，有一个谜团一直让你着迷，不是吗？是的，多米尼克，我一直对人类是如何制造和使用火的问题着迷。它是如何起源的？去年宣布了一项惊人的发现，火的发明地似乎是萨福克（Suffolk）。嗯，你知道，让历史如此迷人的原因之一就是来源之间的那种来回博弈，试图解释这些伟大的谜团。你知道什么适合那种思考方式吗？Claude 就是为那种思考方式而构建的。
It doesn't smooth things over. It helps you dig into the disagreement to reveal something new. Anthropic just committed to not running adverts in Claude, so your thinking stays yours. Try Claude for free at Claude.a.ai slash rest is history. Hello everybody and welcome to the book club, a new podcast from Gollhanger. Hosted by me, Dominic Sambrook. And me, Tabitha Cyrus. As some of you may know, I've been Dominic's producer on The Rest is History.
它不会掩盖问题。它能帮助你深入挖掘分歧，揭示新的东西。Anthropic 刚刚承诺不在 Claude 中投放广告，所以你的思考依然属于你自己。在 claude.ai/restishistory 免费试用 Claude。大家好，欢迎来到“读书俱乐部”（The Book Club），这是 Gollhanger 推出的一个新播客。由我，多米尼克·桑布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）主持。还有我，塔比莎·赛勒德（Tabitha Siread）。正如你们中一些人可能知道的，我曾是多米尼克在《历史的余韵》（The Rest is History）中的制作人。
and we even did a mini-series last year about all things books. And since we enjoyed that so much, we have decided to roll it out as its own show. So it'll be coming out every Tuesday. We'll be doing a different book each time and digging into all the stories behind them. And we are going to be talking about the historical contexts behind some of the greatest and most famous books of all time. We're going to be digging into the remarkable people behind them, the unexpected stories behind the stories, and also unraveling the plot of each book a bit and delving into the depths of the story.
我们去年甚至还做了一个关于书籍的迷你系列。因为我们非常喜欢，所以决定把它作为一个独立的节目推出。它将于每周二播出。我们每次会选一本不同的书，深入挖掘它们背后的所有故事。我们将讨论一些有史以来最伟大、最著名书籍背后的历史背景。我们将深入挖掘它们背后非凡的人物，故事背后的意外故事，同时也会稍微梳理一下每本书的情节，深入探讨故事的内涵。
Now, you don't have to have read the books to listen to the show, but we hope that by the end of each episode, you will be able to pretend to people that you've read them. That is the key thing. And either way, whether you read them or not, we hope that you'll learn lots of fascinating facts,
现在，你不必读过这些书也能收听节目，但我们希望在每一集结束时，你都能假装自己读过它们。这是关键所在。无论如何，无论你是否读过，我们都希望你能学到许多迷人的事实，
you'll do lots of great stories, and maybe Tabby, the odd laugh. We will be looking at thrilling, gothic bodice rippers like Wuthering Heights and Frankenstein, as well as iconic stories like the Great Gatsby or Little Women. And then also some more modern stuff. So Game of Thrones, Normal People, The Hunger Games, Hamnet, all manner of exciting stories.
你会听到许多精彩的故事，也许塔比，还会偶尔笑一笑。我们将关注惊悚的哥特式言情小说，如《呼啸山庄》和《弗兰肯斯坦》，以及像《了不起的盖茨比》或《小妇人》这样的标志性故事。然后还有一些更现代的作品。比如《权力的游戏》、《正常人》、《饥饿游戏》、《哈姆内特》（Hamnet），各种令人兴奋的故事。
So please join us on our journey into all things books, wherever you get your podcasts. Just search for The Book Club every Tuesday, and hopefully we will see you there. Hello, everybody, and welcome to The Book Club, a new podcast from Gollhanger, hosted by me Dominic Sambrook And me, Tabitha Siread.
所以请加入我们的书籍之旅，无论你在哪里收听播客。每周二搜索“读书俱乐部”，希望我们能在那里见到你。大家好，欢迎来到“读书俱乐部”，这是 Gollhanger 推出的一个新播客，由我多米尼克·桑布鲁克主持。还有我，塔比莎·赛勒德。
As some of you may know, I've been Dominic's producer on The Rest is History. And we even did a mini-series last year about all things books. And since we enjoyed that so much, we have decided to roll it out as its own show. Sett will be coming out every Tuesday. We'll be doing a different book each time and digging into all the stories behind them.
正如你们中一些人可能知道的，我曾是多米尼克在《历史的余韵》中的制作人。我们去年甚至还做了一个关于书籍的迷你系列。因为我们非常喜欢，所以决定把它作为一个独立的节目推出。它将于每周二播出。我们每次会选一本不同的书，深入挖掘它们背后的所有故事。
And we are going to be talking about the historical contexts behind some of the greatest and most famous books of all time. We're going to be digging into the remarkable people behind them, the unexpected stories behind the stories, and also unraveling the plot of each book a bit and delving into the depths of the story. Now, you don't have to have read the books to listen to the show, but we hope that by the end of each episode, you will be able to pretend to people that you've read them. That is the key thing.
我们将讨论一些有史以来最伟大、最著名书籍背后的历史背景。我们将深入挖掘它们背后非凡的人物，故事背后的意外故事，同时也会稍微梳理一下每本书的情节，深入探讨故事的内涵。现在，你不必读过这些书也能收听节目，但我们希望在每一集结束时，你都能假装自己读过它们。这是关键所在。
And either way, whether you read them or not, we hope that you'll learn lots of fascinating facts, you'll do lots of great stories, and maybe Tabby, the odd laugh. We will be looking at thrilling Gothic bodice rippers like Wuthering Heights and Frankenstein, as well as iconic stories like The Great Gatsby or Little Women. And then also some more modern stuff. So Game of Thrones, Normal People, The Hunger Games, Hamlet, or manner of exciting stories. So please join us on our journey into all things books, wherever you get your podcasts. Just search for The Book Club every Tuesday and hopefully we will see you there.
无论如何，无论你是否读过，我们都希望你能学到许多迷人的事实，你会听到许多精彩的故事，也许塔比，还会偶尔笑一笑。我们将关注惊悚的哥特式言情小说，如《呼啸山庄》和《弗兰肯斯坦》，以及像《了不起的盖茨比》或《小妇人》这样的标志性故事。然后还有一些更现代的作品。比如《权力的游戏》、《正常人》、《饥饿游戏》、《哈姆雷特》，各种令人兴奋的故事。所以请加入我们的书籍之旅，无论你在哪里收听播客。每周二搜索“读书俱乐部”，希望我们能在那里见到你。
Hello and welcome back to the rest is history. It is April 1533 and for weeks now the gold of the Inca's has been rolling into this room that has a white line round it. The gold has to reach that white line or else Atta Helper is going to be killed. And Dominic, every day that that hoard is getting higher, isn't it? Because you've got streams of porters, streams of lamas and they are just bringing in gold from across Peru and beyond. They are. And Atalper is watching a great satisfaction. because with every new convoy, surely the day of his freedom is approaching. But the Gold Porter is not the only new arrivals in Cahomarker. Just before Easter, a familiar face joins this merry party. And this is Pizarro's business partner, Diego Del Magro. Yeah. We described in episode one, he's short, he's ugly, he's flamboyant, so he's colourfully
大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余韵》。现在是 1533 年 4 月，几周以来，印加人的黄金一直源源不断地涌入这个画着白线的房间。黄金必须达到那条白线，否则阿塔瓦尔帕就会被杀。多米尼克，那堆宝藏每天都在升高，不是吗？因为你有成群的搬运工，成群的骆马，他们正从秘鲁各地及更远的地方运来黄金。确实如此。阿塔瓦尔帕正怀着极大的满足感看着这一切。因为随着每一支新的车队到来，他自由的日子肯定在临近。但黄金搬运工并不是卡哈马卡唯一的新来者。就在复活节前夕，一个熟悉的面孔加入了这个欢乐的派对。这就是皮萨罗的商业伙伴，迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗（Diego de Almagro）。是的。我们在第一集描述过，他个子矮，长得丑，性格张扬，所以他穿得色彩鲜艳，
dress, but he's also very boastful and sort of boorish. John Reese Davies. Yes. Who played Kimley. Exactly. Now remember the deal was that he would get reinforcements in Panama and he would come along later. And this is precisely what he's done. He's arrived with 150 Spaniards with a load more horses and some royal officials who are basically going to report back to the court in Spain to Charles V.
但他也非常爱吹牛，而且有点粗鲁。约翰·里斯-戴维斯（John Rhys-Davies）。是的。那个扮演金利（Gimli）的人。没错。现在记住协议是他在巴拿马获得增援，然后稍后赶来。这正是他所做的。他带着 150 名西班牙人、更多的马匹和一些皇家官员抵达了，这些官员基本上要向西班牙宫廷向查理五世汇报。
So this has massive implications now for both Pizarro and Atuoka. So Pizarro now has his business partner on hand who he has screwed over from the very beginning because he got himself the title of governor, but basically was a commandant of a fort or something cycle for his business partner. And Almagro throughout this whole thing, he's paranoid that he's going to be cut out of the loot. Now, Attawalper, when he sees these guys arrive, he obviously needs to recalibate because clearly there are a lot more Spaniards out there. And he can tell they're not just going to go away when they've got the gold. This is not just a raid. This looks more like an invasion.
所以这对皮萨罗和阿塔瓦尔帕来说都有巨大的影响。现在皮萨罗身边有了他的商业伙伴，而他从一开始就坑了对方，因为他自己获得了总督的头衔，但基本上只是某个堡垒的指挥官之类的，却为他的商业伙伴安排了这些。阿尔马格罗在整个过程中一直很偏执，担心自己会被排除在战利品之外。现在，阿塔瓦尔帕看到这些人到来时，他显然需要重新评估，因为显然外面还有更多的西班牙人。他看得出来，当他们拿到黄金时，他们不会就这样离开。这不仅仅是一次突袭。这看起来更像是一场入侵。
And at this point, Attawalper says to Bizarro, are you? you going home or are you going to stay? I mean, it's been great having you, but, you know, when are you leaving? So I check out the train times and. And for the first time, Pizarro says to him, we are going to stay and we're going to divide up your workers, your people among ourselves. And this is a huge shock for Attaweb. Pizarro says, don't worry, we will leave the northern bit, the province of Quito to you. That's your heartland. It'll be your kingdom. But Attawelper, for the first time things, I don't believe these guys. They are not going to want of this agreement. And is he starting to think, can I even trust them to set me free when
此时，阿塔瓦尔帕对皮萨罗说，你们是要回家还是要留下来？我的意思是，有你们在真是太好了，但是，你们什么时候走？所以我查了一下火车时刻表。第一次，皮萨罗对他说，我们要留下来，我们要把你们的工人，你们的人民在我们之间瓜分。这对阿塔瓦尔帕来说是一个巨大的打击。皮萨罗说，别担心，我们会把北部，基多（Quito）省留给你。那是你的核心地带。那将是你的王国。但阿塔瓦尔帕第一次想，我不相信这些人。他们不会遵守这个协议。他开始想，当
the line gets reached? Exactly, exactly. Now, all the time the gold has been rolling in, as you said, and at the first week of May 1533, Brizarro orders is meant to start melting it down. This is an incredible operation. They've built nine huge forges under Spanish supervision. Inka-Smiths are going to do it, and they are feeding the fires all day. all night, seven days a week, for seven weeks, with more than 600 pounds of gold a day. So that's a total of 11 tons. And we're talking about vases, figurines, idols, ornaments, necklaces, you name it. These are beautiful artifacts, because we know from the very few that were preserved,
达到那条线时，我甚至能相信他们会放我走吗？正是如此，正是如此。现在，正如你所说，黄金一直在源源不断地涌入，1533 年 5 月的第一周，皮萨罗命令手下开始熔化它。这是一项令人难以置信的行动。他们在西班牙人的监督下建造了九个巨大的熔炉。印加铁匠将负责这项工作，他们每天 24 小时、每周 7 天，连续七周都在喂火，每天熔化超过 600 磅的黄金。总共是 11 吨。我们谈论的是花瓶、小雕像、偶像、装饰品、项链，应有尽有。这些都是精美的艺术品，因为我们从仅存的少数几件中知道，
the high standard of Andean kind of gold craftsmanship. Such a tragedy. Imagine what they would be like to have those things. Yeah. And the Spanish turned them into bars. that would be stamped with the royal symbol, and there are going to be 13,500 pounds of gold bars, 16,000 pounds of silver bars, which are all destined to be shipped back to Spain. Now, you remember that I mentioned that Atulper had offered them two temples.
安第斯黄金工艺的高水准。真是太悲剧了。想象一下拥有那些东西会是什么样子。是的。西班牙人把它们变成了印有皇家标志的金条，总共将有 13,500 磅的金条，16,000 磅的银条，所有这些都注定要运回西班牙。现在，你还记得我提到过阿塔瓦尔帕向他们提供了两座寺庙吗？
So one is Pachamak, which we talked about last time, and the other was the Sun Temple of Coricancho in Cusco. and he has now persuaded Pizarro send some men to Cusco to the Sun Temple Cusco is a hell of a long way away, 750 miles across the Central Andes not for people who've been going 800 miles well I guess yeah except you're going across the mountains which is hard
一个是帕查卡马克（Pachacamac），我们上次谈到过，另一个是库斯科（Cusco）的科里坎查（Coricancha）太阳神庙。他现在已经说服皮萨罗派人去库斯科的太阳神庙。库斯科离这里非常远，横跨安第斯山脉中部 750 英里，对于那些已经走了 800 英里的人来说，这可不容易。嗯，我想是的，除了你要翻越山脉，这很难。
Yeah true So when he gets a message from Anando his brother to say Patrick Kamak is no good There's no goal Pizarro says okay fine we'll do it And he sends three volunteers Three I know three volunteers With an escort all the way across the Andes South to Kusko.
是的，没错。所以当他收到他兄弟埃尔南多的消息说帕查卡马克没用，没有黄金时，皮萨罗说好吧，没问题，我们去。他派了三名志愿者。三名，我知道，三名志愿者，带着护卫队一路穿过安第斯山脉向南前往库斯科。
And they get there in early April and they're greeted by Atwellp's general Kiskees, who is occupying Kusko. Now we'll talk a lot about Kusko next time, so we don't need to massively go into it now. But just to talk about the temple, Kodakancher, this was the holiest place that there was for the Inca's. It's the Temple of the Sun. The Inker, of course, is the son of the sun. There is this herb garden, there's a convent. There's an astronomical observatory. John Heming calls it the Mecca of the Inca Empire.
他们在四月初到达那里，受到了阿塔瓦尔帕的将军基斯基斯（Kiskees）的迎接，他当时正占领着库斯科。我们下次会详细谈论库斯科，所以现在不需要深入探讨。但就谈谈那座寺庙，科里坎查，这是印加人最神圣的地方。它是太阳神庙。印加王当然是太阳之子。那里有药草园，有修道院。有一个天文台。约翰·海明称其为印加帝国的麦加。
because pilgrims would come from all over the Andes to visit this place. And even though Kiskees is a northerner, who's put Kusko under military occupation, he's shocked when the Spaniards say, we've come to basically rip out the gold from this temple. I mean, imagine, you know, they turn up in Mecca and say, we've been sent to despoil the mosque. Yeah.
因为朝圣者会从安第斯山脉各地来到这里参观这个地方。尽管基斯基斯是一个北方人，对库斯科进行了军事占领，但当西班牙人说我们来这里基本上是为了从这座寺庙里挖出黄金时，他还是感到震惊。我的意思是，想象一下，你知道，他们出现在麦加说，我们被派来亵渎清真寺。是的。
I didn't go down well. Not at all. And they're very rude. He's very shocked that they're uncouth, and they abuse the women of the temples. That's all we're told. I think we can guess, given the Spanish behaviour earlier in the last episode, exactly how badly behaved they are with the women of the temples.
这可不太好。一点也不。他们非常粗鲁。他非常震惊他们如此粗野，还虐待寺庙里的妇女。我们只被告知了这些。我想考虑到西班牙人在上一集中的行为，我们可以猜到他们对寺庙里的妇女行为有多恶劣。
Seems incomprehensible. They're not just lynched. I know, and there's only three of them. Insane, isn't it? And the mad thing is, Kiscus says, okay, fair enough. And his men fetch tools so that these Spanish guys with crowbars can take these giant gold plates off the walls of the temples. I mean, isn't it that Kiscus is actually, he's in command of an occupying force? Yeah.
似乎不可理解。他们没有被私刑处死。我知道，而且他们只有三个人。太疯狂了，不是吗？疯狂的是，基斯基斯说，好吧，公平合理。他的手下拿来工具，让这些带着撬棍的西班牙人把这些巨大的金板从寺庙墙上拆下来。我的意思是，难道不是基斯基斯实际上在指挥一支占领军吗？是的。
And presumably shares Atowalpa's contempt for what Kusko represents. I'm sure. So in a sense, maybe the Spaniards are doing dirty work that he can't actually do. I suppose, maybe. Because I cannot comprehend how they would be allowed to do this otherwise. Yeah, and maybe. I mean, I think the fact that he's a northerner definitely is a factor, and he's commanding an occupying army.
并且大概也认同阿塔瓦尔帕对库斯科所代表事物的蔑视。我肯定。所以从某种意义上说，也许西班牙人正在做他实际上无法做的脏活。我想，也许吧。因为我无法理解如果没有这样，他们怎么会被允许这样做。是的，也许。我的意思是，我认为他是北方人这一事实绝对是一个因素，而且他正在指挥一支占领军。
But even so, he's part of the Inca world. He believes in the cult of the sun. You know, he's part of that cosmological ecosystem. But they tear it all down. So these great plates, they're about two and a half feet long. They weigh five pounds each. They're beautifully decorated, we're told, with images of trees and flowers and things like that. Solid gold.
但即便如此，他也是印加世界的一部分。他信仰太阳崇拜。你知道，他是那个宇宙生态系统的一部分。但他们把一切都拆毁了。所以这些巨大的金板，大约两英尺半长。每块重五磅。我们被告知它们装饰精美，有树木和花朵之类的图案。纯金。
The Spanish tear it all down. They get hundreds of supporters to carry it back. Of course, no wheels, no carts in Peru. That god for llamas. Yeah. And, I mean, they have hundreds of supporters carrying these things, literally like trudging across the mountains, carrying these great gold plates. They've got these pallets basically loaded with gold and silver.
西班牙人把它们全部拆毁。他们找了数百名搬运工把它们运回去。当然，秘鲁没有轮子，没有马车。感谢上帝有骆马。是的。而且，我的意思是，他们有数百名搬运工背着这些东西，简直就像在山上跋涉，背着这些巨大的金板。他们基本上有装满黄金和白银的托盘。
And when they get back to Cajamaka, Pizarro and the people in Cajamaka just can't believe their eyes. This stream of porters with all the gold of Cusco, 14,000 pounds of gold, 26,000 pounds of silver, combined 20 metric tons of treasure. And at this point, Attawalpa's ransom is unquestionably the biggest ransom ever paid. You know, there's a sort of rabbit hole of economic history where people have tried to quantify how much this is. At the lowest, it's billions of dollars or pounds in today's money. At the highest, it is tens and tens of billions. I mean, it's almost impossible to put a figure on it.
当他们回到卡哈马卡时，皮萨罗和卡哈马卡的人简直不敢相信自己的眼睛。这群搬运工带着库斯科所有的黄金，14,000 磅黄金，26,000 磅白银，总共 20 公吨的宝藏。此时，阿塔瓦尔帕的赎金无疑是有史以来支付的最大赎金。你知道，经济史上有一个所谓的“兔子洞”，人们试图量化这到底是多少钱。按最低计算，相当于今天几十亿美元或英镑。按最高计算，是几百亿甚至上千亿。我的意思是，几乎不可能给它定一个数字。
And Pizarro is part of that chivalric culture where ransoms are taken for granted. And then he is so hit the jackpot with this one. Yeah. I mean, it puts Francis the first into exactly. Very, very low rent. It's as though somebody has basically said to him, how much ransom would you like? And he said, I don't know, a hundred billion pounds. Billion, zillion trillion. Yeah. And they've said, okay, we've got it. You know, here it is. The three Spaniards who turn up back in Kaamauga say, do you know the mad thing? This is only a fraction of the gold in Kusko. They said there was so much gold in all the temples of the city that it was marvelous, they would have brought back much more of it, but it would have detained them longer.
皮萨罗属于那种骑士文化，赎金被认为是理所当然的。然后他这次真是中了头奖。是的。我的意思是，这让弗朗索瓦一世（Francis I）显得非常……没错。非常非常低端。就好像有人基本上对他说，你想要多少赎金？他说，我不知道，一千亿英镑。十亿，万亿，兆亿。是的。他们说，好的，我们有。你知道，就在这里。那三名回到卡哈马卡的西班牙人说，你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？这只是库斯科黄金的一小部分。他们说城市里所有寺庙里的黄金多得惊人，他们本可以带回更多，但这会耽误他们更长时间。
And they said, we've already taken steps to start hoarding it. We've got a big storehouse there, we've got blokes guarding it. Great. And Pizarro and Almaro say, oh my God. So Cusco is next. So this is a thing. See, they're going to want to go on to Cusco. On the 17th of June, Pizarro starts to share out the gold. A fifth of it is set aside for the crown. After that, all of his horsemen will get £90 of gold.
他们说，我们已经采取措施开始囤积它了。我们在那里有一个大仓库，我们有家伙在守着它。太棒了。皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗说，天哪。所以下一个目标是库斯科。所以这是一回事。你看，他们会想去库斯科。6 月 17 日，皮萨罗开始分配黄金。五分之一留给王室。在那之后，他所有的骑兵将获得 90 英镑的黄金。
That's 40 kilos. And they'll get £180 of silver, 81 kilos. Anyone who's not a horseman gets half of this, except for the priests and friars who get even less. I don't know why. They're pledged to poverty. I suppose so. And, of course, the bigwigs get a lot more.
那是 40 公斤。他们将获得 180 英镑的白银，81 公斤。任何不是骑兵的人获得这个数字的一半，除了牧师和修士，他们得到的更少。我不知道为什么。他们发誓要贫穷。我想是吧。当然，大人物们得到的要多得多。
So, Anando de Soto gets double. Francisco Pizarro gets seven times what a horseman gets, and he gets Atulper's solid gold thrown, which is very expensive. And Dominant, what about Diego Almagro, who's turned up and has been systematically frozen out? So, Almagro says to Pizarro, I think the fair thing to do would be to split this equally between us, between your men and my men. And Pizarro says, I don't know, because we kind of did all the dirty work by arriving and catching Atalpa. you came late. So I think what would be best is for you to get just a little token amount.
所以，埃尔南多·德·索托（Hernando de Soto）得到双倍。弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗（Francisco Pizarro）得到的比骑兵多七倍，他还得到了阿塔瓦尔帕的纯金王座，那非常昂贵。多米尼克，那迭戈·阿尔马格罗呢，他出现了却被系统性地排挤在外？所以，阿尔马格罗对皮萨罗说，我认为公平的做法是把这些在我们之间，在你的手下和我的手下之间平分。皮萨罗说，我不知道，因为我们基本上做了所有的脏活，到达并抓住了阿塔瓦尔帕。你来晚了。所以我认为最好是你只得到一点象征性的金额。
And this is what happens. He gives him, you know, a few trinkets, a few crumbs from his table. Remind me what the balance of power is between them. So Amagro has turned up with about 150 men. Pizarra has a few more actually. Pizarra has something like 167, 168. Because it's kind of amazing in that situation that they don't turn on each other. Yes. Well, if you're looking for them to turn on each other, Tom, I've got great news for you. There'll be a lot of turning on each other to come. I mean, if I was a Maldro. Yeah, you go mad.
这就是发生的事情。他给了他，你知道，一些小饰品，从他桌子上掉下来的一些面包屑。提醒我他们之间的权力平衡是什么样的。所以阿尔马格罗带了大约 150 人出现。皮萨罗实际上有更多。皮萨罗有大约 167、168 人。因为在这种情况下，他们没有互相残杀真是太神奇了。是的。好吧，如果你在寻找他们互相残杀，汤姆，我有个好消息告诉你。接下来会有很多互相残杀。我的意思是，如果我是阿尔马格罗。是的，你会疯掉的。
You'd say what? This was always ideal that I would come later, and I come later now and you cut me out. There's an argument that Almagro is being a bit naive. This is how conquistadors always behave. They always stab each other in the back, and you have to be on hand. And actually, Pizarro is a shrewd guy.
你会说，什么？我稍后赶来一直是理想的，我现在稍后赶来，你却把我踢开了。有一种说法是阿尔马格罗有点天真。征服者总是这样行事。他们总是背后捅刀子，你必须在场。事实上，皮萨罗是个精明的人。
For somebody who's basically, you know, is illiterate and he's come from nowhere. He's not a fool. Because he straight away knows, I must get the king on side. I don't want to be Cortez. and end up in constant lawsuits. You know, I must have royal approval.
对于一个基本上，你知道，目不识丁且出身卑微的人来说。他不是傻瓜。因为他立刻知道，我必须争取国王的支持。我不想成为科尔特斯（Cortez），最终陷入不断的诉讼中。你知道，我必须得到皇家的批准。
So he gets his brother, Hernando, and he gives him a written report. Obviously, his secretary has written this for him. And he gives him a load of gold, and he gives him some ornaments. And he says, go back to the coast, go to Panama, then sail on to Spain with all this gold, with this report, go to see the king. Get him to approve my, you know, to reapprove my governorship of this province because we cannot afford to be cut out by somebody else. There's a downside, though, if Anando Pizarro, his brother is going off, because Atta Walper has become great pals with Nando. They're both kind of alpha males and they've kind of bonded over, I don't know, drinking from this skulls. Skals.
所以他找来他的兄弟埃尔南多，给了他一份书面报告。显然，他的秘书已经为他写好了。他给了他一大堆黄金，还给了他一些装饰品。他说，回到海岸，去巴拿马，然后带着所有这些黄金，带着这份报告航行到西班牙，去见国王。让他批准我的，你知道，重新批准我对这个省的总督职位，因为我们不能承担被别人排挤的风险。不过，如果埃尔南多·皮萨罗，他的兄弟离开，有一个缺点，因为阿塔瓦尔帕已经和埃尔南多成了好朋友。他们都是那种阿尔法男性，他们通过，我不知道，从头骨里喝酒建立了联系。头骨。
Vampire bat. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Red trousers made of vampire bats. While just spitting into the hands of beautiful women. Watching the rugger together. Yeah, exactly.
吸血蝙蝠。是的。是的。没错。用吸血蝙蝠做的红色裤子。一边向美丽的女人手上吐口水。一起看橄榄球。是的，没错。
Atta Welper actually bursts into tears. and he says, you know, I'm worried that with you gone, the others will kill me. So he's starting to wake up to that possibility then. And Ando says, I'm sure they won't kill you. No, I've promised you they won't kill you. But once he's gone, Atta Welper gets very miserable. He supposedly sees this comet which foreshadows his death. I think that probably didn't happen. But what did happen, he is extremely concerned about Al-Magro.
阿塔瓦尔帕实际上泪流满面。他说，你知道，我担心你走了，其他人会杀了我。所以他开始意识到那种可能性了。埃尔南多说，我相信他们不会杀你的。不，我向你保证他们不会杀你。但一旦他走了，阿塔瓦尔帕变得非常痛苦。他据称看到了这颗预示他死亡的彗星。我认为那可能没有发生。但确实发生的是，他非常担心阿尔马格罗。
Because Al-Magro didn't capture him, has not spent time with him. It's just impatient to push on to Kusko and get his own share of the good. old. Now, what happens next is a very murky story, so we'll try to find our way through it, one of the murkiest stories of the whole conquest. What happened to Attawelper? Atta Welper said to Pizarra around this point, you know, you've pretty much got what you came for. Most of the ransom has arrived now. I think you can set me free a little bit, give me a bit more freedom to kind of walk around and stuff. Now, there are stories in some sources that one of the interpreters, called Felipeo, had fallen in love with one of Attawelper's mistresses, and
因为阿尔马格罗没有抓住他，没有花时间和他在一起。只是不耐烦地想推进到库斯科，得到他那份好东西。现在，接下来发生的事情是一个非常模糊的故事，所以我们将尝试理清它，这是整个征服过程中最模糊的故事之一。阿塔瓦尔帕发生了什么？阿塔瓦尔帕在这一点左右对皮萨罗说，你知道，你基本上得到了你想要的东西。大部分赎金现在已经到了。我想你可以给我一点自由，让我多一点自由走动之类的。现在，一些来源中有故事说，一名叫费利佩（Felipeo）的翻译爱上了阿塔瓦尔帕的一位情妇，并且
and basically wanted Attawalpa out of the way. So he starts telling the Spanish, oh, Atta Welper is betraying you. Atta Welper is planning to escape. He's planning to team up with Ruminyawi, who's his commander in Quito, who's the guy in the north. It's possible this is just a kind of literary device.
基本上想除掉阿塔瓦尔帕。所以他开始告诉西班牙人，哦，阿塔瓦尔帕在背叛你们。阿塔瓦尔帕正计划逃跑。他正计划与鲁米尼亚维（Ruminyawi）联手，他是他在基多的指挥官，就是北方的那个人。这可能只是一种文学手段。
This didn't really happen. But even if it didn't happen, there is a genuine issue that it points to, which is, the Spanish have become, as time has gone on, more and more anxious about their position in Kahamaaka. They've got all this gold now, which they're sitting on, but they're very conscious that they're outnumbered.
这并没有真正发生。但即使它没有发生，它也指向了一个真正的问题，那就是，随着时间的推移，西班牙人在卡哈马卡的处境变得越来越焦虑。他们现在坐拥所有这些黄金，但他们非常清楚自己寡不敌众。
And they're very worried about an attack from the north. So this guy, Ruminjawi, who's in Ecuador, who is the commander of the army there, they become very worried that he's basically the Jimmy Carter of this story. And he's going to launch a Delta 4-style Operation Eagle Claw rescue to spring Attawalper from his prison in Kajemark. Now, if they were students of history, and they'd listen to our series on the Iranian Revolution. No, nothing to worry there. They would know there was nothing to worry about. Actually, I have to say, as we'll discover next time, two more different people than Rumi Nyawi and Jimmy Carter could not be imagined.
他们非常担心来自北方的攻击。所以这个在厄瓜多尔的家伙，鲁米尼亚维，他是那里的军队指挥官，他们变得非常担心他基本上是这个故事里的吉米·卡特（Jimmy Carter）。他将发起一场“三角洲4号”式的“鹰爪行动”（Operation Eagle Claw）救援，把阿塔瓦尔帕从卡哈马卡的监狱里救出来。现在，如果他们是历史系学生，听过我们关于伊朗革命的系列节目。不，没什么好担心的。他们会知道没什么好担心的。事实上，我必须说，正如我们下次会发现的那样，再也没有比鲁米尼亚维和吉米·卡特更不同的人了。
I mean, Ruminjawi would never appear on TV in a cardigan to tell you to turn the thermostat down. He would turn you into a drum. That's what he would do. There's a little preview for the next episode. So, rumors start to flood into Kiyamaaka that Rumi Nya'i is on his way south. So one local chief says to Pizarro, men are coming under a great commander called Rumi Niawi, 200,000 people from Quito, and 30,000 caribs who eat human flesh. Yeah, so the cannibals are coming.
我的意思是，鲁米尼亚维永远不会穿着开衫出现在电视上告诉你调低恒温器。他会把你变成鼓。这就是他会做的。这是下一集的预告。所以，谣言开始涌入卡哈马卡，说鲁米尼亚维正在向南进发。所以一位当地酋长对皮萨罗说，一支军队正在一位名叫鲁米尼亚维的伟大指挥官带领下赶来，20 万来自基多的人，还有 3 万吃人肉的加勒比人。是的，所以食人族要来了。
Yeah. And the Spanish, of course, take this seriously. Why wouldn't they? It's kind of mad that the Atteualpiz haven't attacked them. And surely they think only a matter of time before Attewepazamis decide they're going to try and rescue him. But I guess ultimately the issue comes down to, are they likely to survive? if Atulah is dead. Or if they release him, can they trust him to be their protector?
是的。西班牙人当然认真对待这一点。为什么不呢？阿塔瓦尔帕的人没有攻击他们真是太疯狂了。而且他们肯定认为阿塔瓦尔帕的人决定尝试营救他只是时间问题。但我猜最终的问题归结为，如果阿塔瓦尔帕死了，他们还能幸存吗？或者如果他们释放他，他们能相信他会成为他们的保护者吗？
That's exactly right. I mean, that's ultimately the decision. They can't make up their minds. And Pizarro, I think, in particular, is very conflicted. They want to go to Costco to get more gold. So what do they do with Atowalpa? They could leave him behind? That's so risky.
完全正确。我的意思是，这最终是决定。他们无法下定决心。我认为皮萨罗尤其感到非常矛盾。他们想去库斯科得到更多的黄金。那么他们怎么处理阿塔瓦尔帕？他们可以把他留在后面？那太冒险了。
He'll just turn on them, surely. They can see he's a hard man. Or number two, they could take him with them across the mountains. but that's risky too. Here we're focused for, you know, resistance. People will try to rescue him. It's so dangerous. The obvious answer, the simplest and cleanest, just get rid.
他肯定会反过来对付他们。他们看得出他是个硬汉。或者第二，他们可以带他一起翻越山脉。但这也很冒险。这里我们专注于，你知道，抵抗。人们会试图营救他。这太危险了。最明显的答案，最简单、最干净的，就是除掉他。
Kill him. That's what Cortez and Co. did with Montezuma. I think that's what Cortez and Co. did. The only thing that sort of cuts against that is, if they wanted to just get rid of him and all this stuff about Rumi Miawe is a pretext for doing what they always wanted to do, why does Pizarro hang around? And why are there so many accounts of him crying?
杀了他。这就是科尔特斯和他的同伙对蒙特祖马（Montezuma）所做的。我想这就是科尔特斯和他的同伙所做的。唯一有点反对这一点的是，如果他们只是想除掉他，而所有关于鲁米尼亚维的事情都是为了做他们一直想做的事情的借口，为什么皮萨罗要拖延？为什么有这么多关于他哭泣的记录？
and being conflicted about it all. We have one account. He goes to see Atta Welp and he says, I've heard rumours that your men are going to come and rescue you and you're communicating with them through your knotted strings. And Atowalpa scoffed at him. Are you joking? What chance would my men have against men as brave as you?
并且对这一切感到矛盾。我们有一个记录。他去见阿塔瓦尔帕，说，我听到传言说你的人要来救你，你正通过打结的绳子与他们交流。阿塔瓦尔帕嘲笑他。你在开玩笑吗？我的人面对像你们这样勇敢的人会有什么机会？
Stop mocking me like this. And clearly some of the Spaniards do believe him. So one of the younger men, a guy called Pedro Catano, remembers that Atowalpa called Pizarro's bluff. If any warriors did come from Keito, they would be coming on my orders. Find out whether it's true. If it is true, then go ahead.
别再这样嘲笑我了。显然，一些西班牙人确实相信他。所以其中一个年轻人，一个叫佩德罗·卡塔诺（Pedro Catano）的家伙，记得阿塔瓦尔帕叫板皮萨罗。如果真的有战士从基多来，他们也是奉我的命令来的。查清楚是不是真的。如果是真的，那就继续。
You can execute me. And the Spanish sources say that Pissarro found this very stressful. He couldn't decide what to do. He ordered Atta well to be chained by the neck at this point to stop him escaping. Is there not a kind of legal dimension to this? Because we've talked throughout how legalistic the Spaniards are. Yes. His entire governorship depends on royal approval.
你可以处决我。西班牙资料说皮萨罗觉得这压力很大。他无法决定该怎么做。他此时下令用颈枷锁住阿塔瓦尔帕，以防他逃跑。这难道没有一种法律层面吗？因为我们一直在谈论西班牙人是多么讲究法律。是的。他的整个总督职位取决于皇家的批准。
Yes. And killing an emperor who you've promised life to, I mean, it's not a good look, is it, from the perspective of the Spanish court? Yeah. I mean, it may not just be kind of humanitarian instincts. It may be a genuine anxiety that he's torn between kind of legalistic imperatives and his sense of what would be practically the best thing to do, which would be to kill him. That's absolutely right. I think, as we will see, he knows perfectly well that Charles V will go ballistic if he finds out that Pizarra has murdered a monarch. I mean, even in this Aztec story, Cortez had to make up a load of nonsense about Montezuma
是的。杀掉一个你已经承诺给予生命的皇帝，我的意思是，从西班牙宫廷的角度来看，这看起来不太好，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，这可能不仅仅是一种人道主义本能。这可能是一种真正的焦虑，他被法律上的必要性和他认为实际上最好的做法（即杀掉他）之间的矛盾所撕裂。完全正确。我认为，正如我们将看到的，他非常清楚，如果查理五世发现皮萨罗谋杀了一位君主，他会暴跳如雷。我的意思是，即使在阿兹特克的故事中，科尔特斯也必须编造一大堆关于蒙特祖马
rebelling, having agreed to, in order to justify murdering Montezuma. And I think this is exactly what Pizarro is facing right now. Mid-July, 1533, he calls a big meeting to decide Attawapa's fate, and all the big guns are there. We're told that Pizarro and the men who had been there from the very beginning want to keep Attawelper alive. They say it's honorable to keep him alive. if they gave him their word because of the ransom, the ransom's been paid,
反叛的废话，在同意之后，为了证明谋杀蒙特祖马是正当的。我认为这正是皮萨罗现在面临的情况。1533 年 7 月中旬，他召开了一次大型会议来决定阿塔瓦尔帕的命运，所有的大人物都在场。我们被告知，皮萨罗和从一开始就在那里的人想让阿塔瓦尔帕活着。他们说，如果他们给了他承诺，因为赎金已经支付，让他活着是光荣的，
we should keep our side of the bargain. They say he's a really useful hostage. Why would you give up a hostage like this? They point out not a single Spaniard has been attacked or injured since they took him prisoner. Clearly, this is working, so let's keep him. And some of them actually clearly are fond of him.
我们应该遵守我们的协议。他们说他是一个非常有用的筹码。你为什么要放弃这样的筹码？他们指出，自从他们俘虏他以来，没有一个西班牙人受到攻击或伤害。显然，这很有效，所以让我们留着他。而且他们中有些人显然确实喜欢他。
You know, we know from the Chronicles and whatnot that there were people who spent their evenings talking to him through the interpreters, you know, and actually said, he's not such a bad guy. I don't think we should kill him. But the people who've come with Alvarado take a very different view. They've got no investment in him. They say he'll be a focus for resistance. The longer this goes on, the more likely it is that his people will turn on us. And crucially, we want to go to Kusco to get our share of the gold. Can we please stop hanging around? Can we
你知道，我们从编年史之类的东西中知道，有些人花晚上时间通过翻译和他交谈，你知道，实际上说，他不是个坏家伙。我不认为我们应该杀了他。但那些和阿尔瓦拉多（Alvarado）一起来的人持非常不同的观点。他们对他没有任何投入。他们说他将成为抵抗的焦点。这种情况持续的时间越长，他的人民反过来对付我们的可能性就越大。最重要的是，我们想去库斯科得到我们那份黄金。请停止拖延好吗？我们可以
get rid? The Spanias can't agree. And Pizarro sends out a scouting party under Enando de Soto to see if this Northern Army really is coming. And while DeSoto is away, the tension mounts, to cut to the chase, there's an evening when they're playing cards. And a Spaniard comes in and says, there's more rumours, there's people saying there are Inca troops approaching the town. And Almagra and Pizarro have a huge row. And then a couple of evenings later, there is another such incident.
摆脱？西班牙人无法达成一致。皮萨罗派出了埃尔南多·德·索托率领的侦察队，去看看这支北方军队是否真的要来了。在德·索托离开期间，紧张局势加剧。长话短说，有一天晚上他们正在打牌，一个西班牙人进来报告说，有更多传言称印加军队正在逼近城镇。阿尔马格罗和皮萨罗发生了激烈的争吵。几天后的一个晚上，又发生了类似的事情。
Local people say they've seen the villages outside fleeing before an Inca army. The Inca Army will be in Kakamaka and two days. days, you know, the moment has come. Now, this army does not exist. There is no attack on Kaka Marka. But as John Heming says in his book, the key to the story is the hysteria and the paranoia that has now seized the Spaniards. They're in the middle and nowhere. They're thousands of miles from home. They're surrounded by 12 million people. They're absolutely terrified now. This gold is going to be taken from them and they're going to be attacked. They've never fought an Inca army actually. They've attacked effectively unarmed Inca's in the square, but that's not
当地人说他们看到村庄外的人们在印加军队面前逃亡。印加军队将在两天内到达卡哈马卡。你知道，时刻到了。然而，这支军队并不存在。卡哈马卡并没有受到攻击。但正如约翰·海明在他的书中所说，这个故事的关键在于现在笼罩着西班牙人的歇斯底里和偏执。他们身处荒郊野外，离家数千里，被1200万人包围。他们现在极度恐惧，担心黄金会被夺走，自己会遭到攻击。他们实际上从未与印加军队交战过。他们只是在广场上袭击了手无寸铁的印加人，但这并不是
the same as a pitched battle where the Inca's are attacking them. I mean, I'd be paranoid in their shoes. Of course you would. Of course you would. So they have another meeting. Almagro and Coe demand another meeting. And this time, it's clear that Pizarro is outnumbered and the royal officials crucially back Almagro up and say, yeah, that's a welcome, must die. And so Pizarro agrees. I don't doubt the sources that Pizarro is very reluctant, because they're kind of unanimous on this point. And he says, fine, quote, Atta whalper must die since he had broken the peace and plotted treason in bringing men to kill the Christians. Now, the Spanish sources disagree on one thing, and actually historians themselves now disagree, was there a trial or wasn't there? Because some said there was, some said there wasn't.
与印加人主动进攻的正面交锋是一回事。我的意思是，如果换做是我，我也会感到偏执。你当然会。你当然会。于是他们又开了一次会。阿尔马格罗等人要求再次开会。这一次，很明显皮萨罗处于少数，而王室官员关键性地支持了阿尔马格罗，说：“是的，阿塔瓦尔帕必须死。”于是皮萨罗同意了。我不怀疑那些称皮萨罗非常不情愿的资料，因为他们在这一点上几乎是一致的。他说：“好吧，阿塔瓦尔帕必须死，因为他破坏了和平，并密谋杀害基督徒。”现在，西班牙资料在一点上有分歧，实际上历史学家们现在也有分歧：到底有没有审判？因为有些人说有，有些人说没有。
I think it's because the conquistadors are so legalistic, they're always so anxious about being, you know, drawn into American style. lawsuits, that they have some kind of rudimentary court martial, because we do have accounts of it. I mean, some kind. So basically, a kangaroo court. Kangaroo court. Pizarra and Almagro are the judges and there's a prosecutor who's basically barking out questions at Attawalper. Did you kill Chwascar?
我认为这是因为征服者们太讲究法律了，他们总是担心被卷入美式诉讼，所以他们进行了一种粗糙的军事法庭审判，因为我们确实有相关的记录。我的意思是，某种形式的审判。所以基本上，这是一场袋鼠法庭。袋鼠法庭。皮萨罗和阿尔马格罗是法官，还有一个检察官，基本上是在对阿塔瓦尔帕咆哮着提问。你杀了瓦斯卡尔吗？
Did you force your subjects to sacrifice women and children to your gods? Were your wars just? Have you been giving orders for the Spaniards to be killed? Some of the Spanish sources say the questions were ridiculous and the interpreters were deliberately mangling the questions and Atta Welper's answers to portray him in the worst possible light. Atta Welper, for all that we've said, he's a very hard man. He's also a very emotional man. He breaks down in tears and he says, I can give you twice as much gold and silver as I've already given you if you'll spare me. And we're told that Pizarro was crying as well. But Pizarra at the end says, you have been found guilty of idolatry, heresy, regicide, fratricide, treason, polygamy, and incest. I mean, they really are throwing the book at him. And the sentence for all this is death. And because he had committed treason, he should die by burning unless he converted to Christianity.
你是否强迫你的臣民向你们的神灵献祭妇女和儿童？你的战争是正义的吗？你是否下令杀害西班牙人？一些西班牙资料说，这些问题很荒谬，翻译人员故意歪曲了问题和阿塔瓦尔帕的回答，以尽可能地抹黑他。尽管我们说了这么多，阿塔瓦尔帕是一个非常坚强的人。他也是一个非常感性的人。他泪流满面地说：“如果你能饶我一命，我可以给你两倍于我已经给你的黄金和白银。”我们被告知皮萨罗也哭了。但皮萨罗最后说：“你被判犯有偶像崇拜、异端、弑君、弑亲、叛国、多妻和乱伦罪。”我的意思是，他们真的把所有罪名都扣在他头上了。所有这些罪名的判决都是死刑。而且因为他犯了叛国罪，他应该被火刑处死，除非他皈依基督教。
Now, this is very worrying for Attawalpa because die by burning is unthinkable for an Inca. if he's going to live on in paradise, in Hanapancha, as the Inca's call it, then his body cannot be burned. Because you can't get into paradise if you've been burned. And they mummify the bodies, don't they? Yes, you must be embalmed. If you're the emperor, and we'll talk about this in the next episode, they will mummify you and then they'll give you your own palace in Kusko,
这对阿塔瓦尔帕来说非常令人担忧，因为对于印加人来说，火刑是不可想象的。如果他想在印加人所说的“哈纳帕查”（天堂）中继续生存，他的身体就不能被焚烧。因为如果你被烧毁了，你就无法进入天堂。他们会把尸体做成木乃伊，不是吗？是的，你必须被防腐处理。如果你是皇帝，我们将在下一集讨论这个问题，他们会把你做成木乃伊，然后给你在库斯科自己的宫殿，
and they'll bring you out at festivals. For royal weddings and things. And parades and processions and things. You'll have your own servants and stuff when you're a mummy. This is terrible if Attau Lepa can't enjoy this future joy. Now, he doesn't have much time to think about it. The trial ends, so-called trial, if there is a trial, ends in the early hours of Saturday, the 26th of July.
在节日里把你带出来。为了皇家婚礼和类似的事情。还有游行和队列之类的。当你成为木乃伊时，你会有自己的仆人等等。如果阿塔瓦尔帕不能享受这种未来的快乐，那就太可怕了。现在，他没有太多时间去考虑这个问题。审判，所谓的审判，如果确实有审判的话，在7月26日星期六的凌晨结束了。
And the Spaniards say we want to get this done by tonight. Basically, A, in case Attawalpa's rescued, or B, in case Pizarro changes his mind. And so that evening, nights falling, Attawelper is led out into the square in Kachamaka, the place where he had been captured before this big crowd, and he's tied to a stake. It's an absolutely kind of heart-rending scene, even though he is a bad man in some ways.
西班牙人说我们想在今晚之前完成这件事。基本上，A，以防阿塔瓦尔帕被救走，或者B，以防皮萨罗改变主意。于是那天晚上，夜幕降临，阿塔瓦尔帕被带到卡哈马卡的广场上，也就是他之前被俘虏的地方，在众目睽睽之下，他被绑在木桩上。这绝对是一个令人心碎的场景，尽管他在某些方面确实是个坏人。
He's sobbing like a baby. He says, I want to entrust my children to Pizarro's protection. And Valverde, the Dominican friar, says to him, you know, forget about your children. Accept baptism and die like a Christian. We're told Attauilper continued to persist in commending his sons with great weeping, indicating their sighs with his hand, showing by the signs he made and by his words that they were small and that he was leaving them in keto. And eventually, Valverde says, well, you know, Pizarro will look after them and he'll, as though they're his own children.
他像个孩子一样啜泣。他说：“我想把我的孩子们托付给皮萨罗保护。”多米尼加修士瓦尔韦德对他说：“忘掉你的孩子吧。接受洗礼，像基督徒一样死去。”我们被告知阿塔瓦尔帕继续痛哭流涕地托付他的儿子们，用手示意，通过他的手势和言语表明他们还小，他要把他们留在基多。最终，瓦尔韦德说：“好吧，皮萨罗会照顾他们的，就像对待他自己的孩子一样。”
And Atu Elper says, fine, in that case, I'll accept baptism and I'll become a Christian. And the irony there is that he's doing that to preserve his, you know, his supernatural potency in the kingdom of the gods. Yeah. So. Yes, exactly. Valverde then baptizes him and he gives him the name Francis. Francisco, of all names. And then he's not going to be burned. The guards tie a cord around Attawalpa's neck. And as Valverde leads the Spaniards in reciting the creed, Attaualpa is garotted. So that is the end of him. But a couple more details. First of all, the Spanish, of course, had promised him he would not be burned. Now, they don't burn him to ashes. They grill him. They give him a grilling. And then they leave his grilled body in the the square overnight, quote, for everyone to learn of his death. As that basically a message.
阿塔瓦尔帕说：“好吧，既然这样，我接受洗礼，我愿意成为基督徒。”讽刺的是，他这样做是为了保留他在神灵王国中的超自然力量。是的。没错。瓦尔韦德随后为他施洗，并给他取名为弗朗西斯。弗朗西斯科，竟然是这个名字。然后他不会被火烧了。守卫在阿塔瓦尔帕的脖子上系了一根绳子。当瓦尔韦德带领西班牙人背诵信经时，阿塔瓦尔帕被绞死了。这就是他的结局。但还有几个细节。首先，西班牙人当然答应过他不会被火烧。现在，他们没有把他烧成灰。他们烤了他。他们对他进行了“烧烤”。然后他们把烤过的尸体留在广场上过夜，“让每个人都知道他的死讯”。这基本上是一个信息。
And that grilling, I think, is a gesture, you know, you and I talk about this before we started recording. I think this is a gesture of contempt for him, probably by the Almagreasters. So he's buried, isn't he, in the local church? Yes. But there are stories that people rescue the body, take it to Ecuador, up to keto, and mummify it. Yeah. And there are kind of archaeologists who go Honor. Indiana Jones type, yes, exactly. Maybe out there, Attawalpa's mummified body. Maybe. Lightly grilled is still there. Who knows? Yeah, I mean, it's perfectly possible. There is not, I think, straight away, but I think in subsequent decades, there starts to be this kind of cult of Atowalpa and a belief that maybe he might come back from the dead. Pedro Pizarro records a very weird scene.
而且那种烧烤，我认为是一种姿态，你知道，你和我在这之前讨论过。我认为这是对他的蔑视，可能是阿尔马格罗派的人干的。所以他被埋在当地的教堂里，对吧？是的。但有故事说人们救出了尸体，把它带到厄瓜多尔，带到基多，并把它做成了木乃伊。是的。有一些考古学家去寻找它。印第安纳·琼斯那种，是的，没错。也许在那里，阿塔瓦尔帕的木乃伊还在。也许吧。被轻微烤过的尸体还在那里。谁知道呢？是的，我的意思是，这完全有可能。我认为不是马上，但在随后的几十年里，开始出现这种对阿塔瓦尔帕的崇拜，并相信他可能会死而复生。佩德罗·皮萨罗记录了一个非常奇怪的场景。
Basically, two of Atalpa's sisters got into Pizarro's apartment and, quote, began to call for Attawalpa searching very softly for him in all the corners. But seeing that he did not answer, they went out making a great lamentation. I disabused them and told them that dead men do not return. The really interesting thing, though, is the reaction of the Spanish themselves. Remember I said that they'd sent off Enando to Soto to look for this northern army? Soto gets back and he says, there's no northern army. I mean, it's been made up.
基本上，阿塔瓦尔帕的两个姐妹进入了皮萨罗的公寓，开始呼唤阿塔瓦尔帕，在所有角落里轻轻地寻找他。但看到他没有回答，她们走出去发出了巨大的哀叹。我劝阻了她们，告诉她们死人是不会回来的。然而，真正有趣的是西班牙人自己的反应。还记得我说过他们派埃尔南多·德·索托去寻找那支北方军队吗？索托回来后说，根本没有北方军队。我的意思是，那是编造出来的。
There's no Inca troops advancing on the town. And then he discovers they've killed Attawalpa and he goes, absolutely ballistic. And he says, how could you do this behind my back when I was gone? I'm meant to be the number two man in this expedition. You've killed this guy who was our chief hostage and one of our biggest assets. Now, meanwhile, Pizarro, one of his secretaries, writes a report for him to Charles V, saying, I have executed a monarch, but I'm just going to explain exactly why I've done it. And the reaction in Spain was that Pizarro had behaved badly, not that Pizarro had done the right thing, but the Pizarro had let Spain down.
根本没有印加军队向城镇推进。然后他发现他们杀了阿塔瓦尔帕，他简直气疯了。他说：“当我离开的时候，你们怎么能在我背后做这种事？我应该是这次远征的二号人物。你们杀了这个家伙，他是我们主要的人质，也是我们最大的资产之一。”与此同时，皮萨罗的一名秘书为他写了一份报告给查理五世，说：“我处决了一位君主，但我会解释我为什么要这样做。”而在西班牙的反应是，皮萨罗的行为很糟糕，并不是说皮萨罗做了正确的事，而是皮萨罗让西班牙失望了。
So there's a judge in Panama or Gaspard Espinoza who's writing all the time to Charles V, basically sending him reports of what these guys are getting up to in Peru. And he writes to Charles the 5th and he says the Spanish and Kakamaka are totally out of control. Their greed is so great as to be insatiable. The more the native chiefs give,
所以巴拿马有一位法官加斯帕尔·埃斯皮诺萨，他一直在给查理五世写信，基本上是向他发送这些人在秘鲁所作所为的报告。他写信给查理五世说，卡哈马卡的西班牙人完全失控了。他们的贪婪大到无法满足。当地酋长给的越多，
the more the Spaniards kill or torture them to give even more. He says they should never have killed that to Alpa, a man who'd fallen into their hands and who'd done no harm to any Spaniard. They could have sent him here to Panama, with his wives and servants as his rank deserved. We would all have honored him and treated him like a great noble of Castile. And actually, this becomes this established, this will surprise some listeners who just think of this, you know, who have subscribed to the black legend of Spain, of 16th century Spain as uniquely cruel and, you know, greedy and whatnot. Most Spanish chroniclers agreed that Pizarro had done the wrong thing.
西班牙人杀害或折磨他们的次数就越多，以索取更多。他说他们本不应该杀死阿塔瓦尔帕，一个落入他们手中且没有伤害任何西班牙人的人。他们本可以把他和他的妻子仆人一起送到巴拿马，正如他的地位所应得的那样。我们都会尊重他，像对待卡斯蒂利亚的伟大贵族一样对待他。实际上，这成为了一个定论，这会让一些听众感到惊讶，他们只是认为，你知道，那些订阅了16世纪西班牙“黑色传说”的人，认为西班牙人极其残忍、贪婪等等。大多数西班牙编年史家都同意皮萨罗做错了事。
So this is Gonzalo Fernandez de Oviedo in their 1530s. The killing of so great a prince was an infamous disservice to God and the emperor, an act of great ingratitude and outstanding evil. And this is probably most influential of all the Spanish writers about Peru, Pedro Theeitha de Leon in the 1550s. The most evil deed the Spaniards have done in all the empire of the Indies. It is widely vituperated and it's considered a grave sin. And this is definitely what the king himself thought, Charles V.
这是贡萨洛·费尔南德斯·德·奥维耶多在16世纪30年代的观点。杀害如此伟大的君主是对上帝和皇帝的恶劣亵渎，是一种极大的忘恩负义和突出的邪恶行为。而这可能是所有关于秘鲁的西班牙作家中最具影响力的，16世纪50年代的佩德罗·西萨·德·莱昂。这是西班牙人在整个印度群岛帝国所做的最邪恶的事情。它受到广泛谴责，被认为是一种严重的罪孽。这绝对是国王查理五世本人的想法。
because when he wrote back to Pizarro, he said, we have been displeased by the death of Attau Leper since he was a monarch, and particularly as it was done in the name of justice, we will seek more information about this matter and then order what is necessary. And if you're Pizarro reading this, you surely think, oh no. And that's probably what Pizarro is worrying about. Exactly that reaction. Attawalper is dead.
因为当他回信给皮萨罗时，他说：“我们对阿塔瓦尔帕的死感到不满，因为他是一位君主，特别是这是以正义的名义进行的，我们将寻求关于此事的更多信息，然后下达必要的命令。”如果你是皮萨罗读到这些，你肯定会想，哦不。而这可能正是皮萨罗所担心的。正是那种反应。阿塔瓦尔帕死了。
And Pizarro's position is looking a little bit rickety. So his brother Hernando on whom he relied has gone back to Spain with some of the gold. His chief lieutenant, Anando de Soto, is furious with him about the death of Attauelper. And his partner, Diego de Amagro, is absolutely furious. Yeah, he's livid. Yeah, livid. He is livid. About the unequal division of the treasure.
皮萨罗的地位看起来有点摇摇欲坠。所以他所依赖的兄弟埃尔南多带着一些黄金回到了西班牙。他的首席副官埃尔南多·德·索托对阿塔瓦尔帕的死感到愤怒。而他的合伙人迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗也绝对愤怒。是的，他非常愤怒。是的，非常愤怒。因为宝藏分配不均。
And now, Pizarro and his men are facing their biggest challenge yet. Attawelper is dead and the empire is leaderless. So they need to find a new puppet on whom they can rely. And Tom, their road now lies south, up into the Andes, across the Inca heartland, to the city of Gold, Cusco. But what awaits them there is darker and bloodier and more dramatic than even they could possibly have imagined. Well, dear listeners, if you like darkness and blood-stained drama, then wow, we've got to treat for you in the next episode. Members of the Restis History Club, of course, can hear it right away, together with the final two episodes in this series. And if you're not a member of the Restis History Club, then you can join them by going to the Restis History.com to sign up.
现在，皮萨罗和他的手下正面临着他们迄今为止最大的挑战。阿塔瓦尔帕死了，帝国群龙无首。所以他们需要找到一个新的傀儡来依靠。汤姆，他们的路现在向南延伸，进入安第斯山脉，穿过印加的心脏地带，到达黄金之城库斯科。但等待他们的东西比他们想象的还要黑暗、血腥和戏剧性。好吧，亲爱的听众们，如果你喜欢黑暗和血腥的戏剧，那么哇，我们在下一集里有精彩的内容等着你。当然，历史俱乐部的成员可以立即收听，以及本系列的最后两集。如果你不是历史俱乐部的成员，那么你可以通过访问网站注册加入他们。
But for now, Asteroa. Bye-bye. Anthony Scaramucci here. As much as I love talking politics, and let's be honest, it sometimes gets me in trouble. My other and probably safer passion is books.
但现在，再见。我是安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇。尽管我喜欢谈论政治，而且老实说，这有时会给我惹麻烦。我的另一个可能更安全的爱好是书籍。
We just dropped our 200th episode on my podcast, Open Book, another Goalhanger show. And to celebrate, we spoke with none other than Waterstones and Barnes & Noble CEO, James Dawn. Let's take a listen. It's a phenomenal piece of technology.
我们刚刚在我的播客《Open Book》中发布了第200集，这是另一个Goalhanger节目。为了庆祝，我们采访了沃特斯通书店和巴诺书店的首席执行官詹姆斯·道恩。让我们听听。这是一项了不起的技术。
James. Everything has changed. Our phones have changed, our computer. The way we look at the TV, the book is a 500-year-old piece of technology. You think in 500 years it'll be with us, James? I think so, and I think it's astonishing simply how extraordinarily durable it is and effective it is. And as you say, newspapers, we don't read them anymore. It's on your iPad. It's on your phone. Music, the format changes all the time. Not with books. And I think when publishers also concentrate on the physical attributes of a book as well, they are lovely things and treasures forever there may be too many books being published right at this moment you believe that and tell us why far far too many books and it's getting ever ever worse this is speaking
詹姆斯。一切都变了。我们的手机变了，我们的电脑变了。我们看电视的方式变了，书是一项有500年历史的技术。你认为500年后它还会和我们在一起吗，詹姆斯？我想会的，而且我认为它如此非凡的耐用和有效，这令人惊讶。正如你所说，报纸，我们不再读它们了。它在你的iPad上。它在你的手机上。音乐，格式一直在变。书不是这样。而且我认为当出版商也专注于书的物理属性时，它们是可爱的物品，是永远的宝藏。此刻出版的书可能太多了，你相信吗？告诉我们为什么。书实在太多了，而且情况越来越糟。这是作为
as a bookseller who crafts a physical space so i only have so much space and there's more and more and lots of self-publishing nothing wrong with writing a book and wanting to see it out in the world but for myself i have to curate all the time and the bit that i regret is that people get upset with me for not carrying their book well i just can't I don't have the space for it. And that's really what I mean. The fact that they sell on Kindle or they sell on Nook or online is fine by me. I want people reading.
一个精心打造物理空间的书商在说话，所以我只有这么多空间，而且越来越多，有很多自出版的书。写书并希望看到它出现在世界上并没有错，但对我自己来说，我必须一直进行策展。我感到遗憾的是，人们因为我不卖他们的书而对我感到不满，好吧，我实在做不到。我没有空间放它们。这就是我真正想表达的意思。它们在Kindle、Nook或网上销售对我来说没问题。我希望人们阅读。
But I myself have to curate. And the reality is that I can't take the vast majority of books that are published. I hope you enjoyed that clip. To hear more from James Dawn and others, subscribe to Open Book with Anthony Scaramucci wherever you get your podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我自己必须进行策展。现实情况是，我无法接受绝大多数出版的书籍。希望你喜欢这段剪辑。要从詹姆斯·道恩和其他人那里听到更多内容，请在任何你获取播客的地方订阅安东尼·斯卡拉穆奇的《Open Book》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。